crypto this isn't all of the ones that
somehow make a living on crypto but the
ones that we could say are employed in a
way so if we say take the examples of
the biggest companies such as coinbase
uh they I think they report somewhere
around 3.6 thousand people binance
roughly uh uh
2,500 we take 10 of those companies 50
companies of the size of like roughly EF
or nethermind having 250 uh 100 smaller
projects l1's l2s uh you name it at like
50 uh 50 people a team uh 500s of
startups of the size of pondal thousands
of early stage projects and tens of
thousands of like team ups uh that's
roughly 100,000 people um that we can
say are employed in crypto uh which
isn't a lot obviously um What's the
total market cap this should be the
up-to-date number from this morning so
the tokens the tokens and coins only uh
result in 3.2 uh trillion dollar um
there is also the market cap which we
didn't include in the crypto native
economy report but it's the the crypto
economy itself there would be companies
like binance like micro strategy maybe
even Robin Hood uh uh we would be
somewhere below $200 billion I think
coinbase is at like $ 85 billion of of
market cap plus there is a ton of
companies that are private privately
owned still like binance chainis chain
analysis like opy all of those would
rank in in billions obviously binance
very likely much higher than that um so
how how does this reflect on the the
rest of the economy uh the so-called
Real World
um to compare these two we basically
picked these three metrics the market
caps the revenues and the people uh and
I hope this will give you some
perspective about where we stand today
so comparing the market caps um we
basically took the stock market cap uh
we take like the stock market cap is
again the imperfect metric um you can
you can take that as like demand to
somehow participate on those assets um
that either can act as a store of value
or act as a promise of future value uh
in form of revenues uh so the entire
stock uh the entire like Tech stock
market by the way there are overlaps
between these um would be today Valu
that uh $33 trillion uh the banking
sector the publicly traded banks10
billion uh 101 trillion
energy sector likewise PHA uh six uh $6
trillion gaming
4.2 uh and then there's crypto at like
3.8 um then there is auto automotive um
so basically all of the car
manufacturers and this is this is very
real right like we would all agree that
like that's the real world and crypto is
actually already valued uh more than uh
more than this part of the real world um
then you have entertainment at two
trillion food industry that's basically
the large corporations we definitely
don't go deeper into like the UR economy
behind like the food industry or any of
these just the publicly traded companies
and finally Airlines there's one thing I
want to uh focus on which is the gaming
and entertainment
comparism um here are the revenue
estimates let's just do a quick read
through but let's focus on the
entertainment and gaming uh so the
entertainment uh even though it's valued
lower than the gaming industry and there
is a partial overlap um is nearing
um uh $900 billion and the the gaming is
at like $600 billion in revenues crypto
including the crypto native part
including the stake and rewards
including the revenues of like binance
and going Bing cracken so on I would
argue it's like still below like 100 100
billion dollars um now following up on
the people metric uh uh this is the
rough estimate of like how many people
are employed by these sectors and
obviously like there's over three
billion people who are
employed somewhere are making a Liv in
so this is again just zoomed in on the
stock companies um but there is an
important like interesting and important
fact here look at entertainment and
gaming where gaming is like valued uh
higher than entertainment entertainment
still makes a bigger Revenue um um but
also employs uh more than twice as many
people as the entertainment as such uh I
would argue that the gaming industry is
ially a more
effective um form of entertainment where
um the the value per an individual in
the
segment uh is much higher than the
overall entertainment um because they
just create something more efficiently
they create content that can like scale
better that can people and people can
stay with the content for much longer my
argument would be crypto does very
similar thing for finance and like we
are still
in this very very early stages of just
few hundred or few hundred thousand
people working in the ecosystem uh and
we're yet to see basically the full
scope of where where crypto can actually
compete with the rest of the of the of
the financial ecosystem and economy um
so that's that's a rough comparism in
numbers um I think we are still very
early I mean we're obviously like
Bitcoin was started in uh 2009 um the
worldwide web was started in 19
um 1989 and look where where it has led
us multiple companies from the internet
era being in the top 10 um this is was
actually isn't the up-to-date slide I
had to update it this morning because
Bitcoin again like popped up into being
the ninth most valuable um asset asset
in the world this is from the infinite
market cap um ethereum is quite close
it's the it's a number it's actually 32
now uh and I would say within a year we
actually again see e room to uh get
Passover like the the Giants like
Mastercard or VISA um as as a contender
in this like globalized ecosystem and if
you look at all of these companies I
think it's like very hard to argue
against crypto being the real thing like
this this is very real this is very
tangible and it already competes with
like companies like Home Depot Costco or
like whatever or xxon mobile um so um
it's definitely nowhere nowhere near
kind of just like a gimmick for for a
few individuals uh so quick summary um
you are the Crypton native economy since
you're here I guess like you somehow
participate in this ecosystem you all
paid like fees on l1s l2s I would
definitely encourage you to read the
reports and give us some feedback um um
I'm wearing the T-shirt Banks ha us it's
usually my final slide but I'm not using
it today but bangs Haas because we are
winning um and I had multiple talks on
the Crypton native economy and the
Crypton native gener ation uh where
argued that in the especially the big
inevitable Market we are at the stage of
like now they're fighting us and I think
we are now finally in the stage of uh of
actually uh getting the recognition and
being considered real from the rest of
the world
um before I depart um this is a slide
that I used in 2022 exactly like in the
bare Market um which basically looked at
the Crypton native economy numbers and
just like concluded was actually super
small uh despite the
uh despite the valuations um and it was
peanuts back then it's still peanuts
today uh but there's another peanut um
is a inide joke I'm not a trump
supporter uh but I just think peanut is
hilarious uh and I would just say like
crypto is very real today already uh
today we're past the uh first they um
ignore us then they will ridicul us and
then they will fight us I think today
we're at the stage where crypto started
winning finally and I can't wait to see
what what happens in the next few years
um thank you all for coming well I think
we have a couple minutes for
questions that was awesome thank you so
much Joseph you can scan this QR code
and write questions we have a couple
minutes to answer your questions but
please we need to do it through the
through the QR code you just you just
take the code
and then you can play your question and
I will help you with that so I'll give
you one minute to do that
meanwhile um I wanted to say it's
fantastic to have you all here this
Defcon 7 is going to be epic it's going
to be amazing and all of us and all of
you being part of this is really
fantastic so I want you to give yourself
an Applause for being here today please
no questions
yet I I saw someone raising a hand
should we just do the questions from
people that raised the hand there is a
gentleman right
here we can try that
meanwhile sure we can come on sure we
can sure we
can they're giving me directions just
just just a second
so so anyone wants to shout a
question
please yes I'll
go so where you say we are and the first
they ignore you then they laugh at you
then they fight you then you win you're
assuming that we're right now in the
middle of the they're fighting us or
that we've passed that they're fighting
us that seems very naive don't you think
there's much more much harder fights
probably in the near future I mean there
will be but I think like at this stage
we are we basically are past the past
the the our fighting s there is there is
like a lot of lot of like embracement in
crypto and you see it like take
Switzerland as a as a as an example um
even like us first starting company
Switzerland we got rejected by multiple
Banks including like the T and like Sur
Cal Banks and so on um and last year
they started providing the same crypto
services to their regular customers and
it's just like that that's the that's
the early birds right and I would say
like we are going to see more and more
even banks that will start custom
services for crypto users uh because the
the economic demand is there and like
more and more even traditional fintax uh
are embracing that and they they just
see it as a revenue Stream So I say like
now now we're vinning in the sense of
getting the recognition and actually
like getting them integrated into our
our own ecosystem um maybe naive but um
like being in the ecosystem for quite a
bit I'm I'm quite optimistic about this
being the stage right
now perfect so now we have questions on
the on the CER so Joseph could you
please talk a bit about consumer
payments in crypto staes as a real world
usage of
tech um that I mean I'm not sure how
much time we have but I think it's
actually becoming like realer with the
l2s
uh with the providers that like pay your
gas fees like three years ago that would
be very um very hard I used to
collaborate with this like group that
was running a crypto only Cafe um and it
was it was a burden like actually paying
for gas fees and like teaching people
like how it works uh many people used it
but definitely wasn't a real world use
case I would say now with like um like
gas being paid for you on l2s it's like
very uh very possible um and I
mean I'm sure we are going to see more
businesses just like accepting crypto
regularly and it's it's it's been
happening for a decade now especially in
the past like few
years fantastic thank you so much Joseph
please give a big Applause for Joseph
and this great thought appreciate it
thank
you thank you
[Music]
I
for e
[Music]
coming next we have de leis with REM
reimagining ler zero new worlds and
ancient philosophies leis he has lived
almost all his life here in Southeast
Asia East Asia and surroundings please
give him a warm welcome welcome to the
[Applause]
[Music]
stage thank you so much hello everybody
and welcome to Devcon welcome to Bangkok
uh before I start uh we're going to do
something a bit different I think many
of us have just had lunch we've sort of
been easing into this air conditioned
close space so if you like I welcome you
to to stand up for just a few
seconds and
just stretch and just stretch that body
and you can stretch all the way up you
can go in your toes if you like left and
right yeah there's a lot of talk a lot
of talk about the future what's
important and sometimes it's important
to get back to our bodies and let's
together just take three deep breaths
and just ground into the
space so you can breathe
in and breathe out
breathe
in breathe
out and breathe
in and
out and invite you to take your seat
again thank you for breathing with me
thank you for breathing all together um
the title of this talk is layer zero uh
reimagining and thinking about ancient
Phil philos oph to build new worlds U my
name is Dave um yes that's my name and
no I'm not a Dev um and I represent
different spaces thinking about
technology and how we can Align
Technology more towards our planet and
human values um so I've had this
question a lot a lot of people ask me so
what I mean by a layer
zero and I want to start off actually
I've been in inspired by the layer Zero
from the web3 and the crypto space you
know we have layer ones and we've talked
about this morning we heard from a about
her vision of the infinite Garden uh
about decentralization about open source
The Cypher Funk movement all of these
values that align ethereum all of these
values that bring us together to build
decentralized Tech to build these new
worlds and that's amazing that's amazing
that we have this technology that allows
us to do this to build stable coins to
to build the kinds of tech that we can
self custody and really uh take
ownership um and so these provide the
values of layer zero of layer of the
infinite
Garden um where with layer zero uh is
going deeper going into the invisible
layer that human layer um the values
that really make us as beings make us as
a civilization and make up us as a
planet and this these values that we
embody is ultimately what's diffused
into the technology and what's created
so trauma we all grew up in different
parts of the world and we've all
suffered through all kinds of violence
from childhood from some of us have
grown up in Conflict zones uh today many
of us live in areas where there is war
and violence uh belief systems our ideas
of who we are what do we want what makes
us happy all of these things that drive
us to get more money to find Fame to
find recognition these things that are
driving us invisible ways and this human
layer this layer zero is really critical
because without this everything that we
want to build these Dows the network
States ethereum itself will face
challenges and will fa and and will
struggle to to really
grow um there's this beautiful quote uh
from J Krishna Muti a world is a
reflection of our inner Minds um and so
it's our minds how we think how we
imagine what we think about ourselves
and the world that we want to build
there ultimately a is reflected outside
of us each one of us in a decentralized
fashion contributing to this world that
we all live in and what happens when we
don't have very clean Minds right uh you
know we're all living we've all we've
all been through this and it doesn't
matter web 3 web 2 technology space in
general the economy in general these are
the kinds of the cultures that our
societies and the culture of our time
really value um and you know we like to
place a lot of blame on the individual
but the individuals are products of the
culture that we create and that we're
part of free Basics again web 2 web 3
doesn't really make a difference right
uh we have we're building these
technology systems we're supposedly
trying to create aote connected world
yeah we're doing in ways that are
ultimately centralizing and ultimately
monopolizing power and ultimately
pulling away from um from these human
values this beautiful blog web 3 is
going great that just captures the many
many scams that you know are part of
this industry and we can't ignore that
uh you know the dgen cultures that are
part of it and that can be celebrated
and that's great and we should celebrate
all cultures of plurality of cultures as
we heard from uh Audrey Tang just just a
moment ago yet we have to have to also
be real that if we want to transcend
these problems we really have to bring
our reflection back into what is it that
we continue to create these problems um
we're living today in a unbalanced Dark
Forest World um many of you may have
read the three body problem uh science
fiction series that looks at how uh the
theory that like our world is ultimately
governed by fear where we're encouraged
to be silent not be open and the world
that we're living today is a reflection
again of our inner minds and so these
are our inner Minds that we have to
contend with that we have to make peace
with war violence our environment
turning around us for those of us in
Thailand we just went through one of the
largest floods in recorded history many
of you coming from all over the world
experiencing your own disasters your own
uh
problems and there's been a lot of
research uh over the last 10 years to
actually show how many of the problems
in our digital spaces the very problems
that web 3 itself the idea of three
being different from two was created the
idea being of owning is is because it's
trying to transcend these problems yet
as this research is showing as the
problems are systemic the problems are
deeply rooted into our political systems
into our into our economic systems into
our very systems of being um Tim Woo's
book master switch talks about how all
of media when it started right from fax
to the telegram up to the internet has
started decentralized has started open
but ultimately Market forces capture
multi Market forces State forces create
a centralization and so as we're sitting
today in this etherium space in this
web3 space we have to be aware that we
are against the very forces that
actually animate our being the forces
that actually create centralization is
not out there it is not a dark evil
force trying to centralize it is all
part of us and we are part of these
systems and so if we want to transcend
if we want to create this decentralized
infinite Garden we really need to bring
more awareness to what makes us our own
minds and makes our own
beings and um in uh there's a wonderful
essay on cryptos 3 body problem uh which
brings about um again this not that if
crypto is to survive crypto needs to
contact with cultures more full-bodied
than crypto itself and so the next phase
must require protocols Beyond just
incentives and smart contracts we need
to integrate with this human layer with
the layer zero we need to integrate with
this level this layer of values and it's
through these layer values that we can
start to move um one of a framework of
change known as the causal layer
analysis popular for thinking about
transformation change also highlights
this that for the most powerful and
meaningful change to happen we have to
go deep under what we see tends to be
just the tip of the iceberg we want to
go deep into the level of World Views
the the philosophies that govern us the
myths and the metaphors what is it that
makes us alive what is it that drives us
what is it that makes life alive how do
we understand these um and so this is
where uh uh sort of coming to in ter
terms of thinking of okay how do we
build these new Worlds how do we build
this infinite garden and um layer zero
sitting right down
there so we all standing here in
Thailand in Southeast Asia we we heard
this morning as well on the kind of
values of the mandala value that a
shared as well around circles and how
that has played a role in this region um
Asian philosophies particularly two
philosophies I want to bring up about
bring up here on Buddhism and DSM have
been a GPS for layer zero navigation in
Asia for thousands of years they've
helped people understand themselves
they've helped people create societies
that are ultimately very linked to human
values and to human flourishing and uh
these systems have existed um and I
think they they're very interesting for
us to look at today especially as we
build decentralized Tech and thinking
again about decentralizing power and
creating more
openness
um because all these philosophies and
particularly Buddhism DSM they emphasize
that there is only one problem it's
really simple it's disconnection
disconnection from each other and
disconnection from the web of life
around us and it is in the state of
disconnection that we act from fear that
we Act without feeling Comfort without
grounding it is from this disconnection
that we fight and we look for to towards
violence and so the only way towards
really recreating new worlds is to
reconnect and to move away from the
state of
disconnection um there is research
emerging now that has been looking at
the different cosmologies of technology
and understanding that technology itself
can be understood from many different
philosophies and worldviews um we don't
have time today to go deep into any of
these works but I'll mention a few key
ideas that I think can be useful for us
to Think Through uh one of them is from
the idea of Cosmo technices and Cosmo
Technologies in China um which is really
looking at how technology itself and the
fundamental ethical principle of
everything in our world is to keep us
more aligned with nature and with our
true nature and so even the role of
technology is to keep us in balance with
each other and in balance with nature
and Technology itself is fundamentally
just as part of nature as all of us it
contains matter it contains um uh
minerals it contains nature and part of
all of us and this idea that we exist as
separate selves each of us individual
disconnect from each other our minds and
bodies disconnected itself is something
that's only really been a notion for the
last 3 to 400 years uh for thousands of
years this idea that of disconnection
itself uh was never there um in in
Chinese Cosmo Technics yuk a scholar
brings up this idea of daou and she as a
way to think about how we can um think
about technology and our relationship
with it um very quickly the idea of the
da is the universe the cosmos the web of
life that everything exists within um
and Chi is a concept of uh tra is
concept of technology tracing back
mostly to confusion principles this idea
of how technology plays a role in
aligning our society to be more aligned
with life and today our technology is
disconnected from the da today our
technology is disconnected from this web
of life and so we have today a world
where we are living with a very
disconnected space and so the idea of
the framing is to think about is how do
we how do we reconnect um how do we
reconnect technology to the universe how
do we reconnect technology to the DA and
these are seemingly initially very
difficult to to grasp and and fathom but
there are ways where we can start
thinking about it what does it mean to
connect technology to the cosmos to the
Dao um here there's another concept from
DA's cosmology thinking about
intelligence and what is the source of
intelligence and how can we get
intelligence from this Web of Life um in
in this cosmology there's two types of
knowledge there's conscious knowledge
which is this everyday awareness of life
um essentially I'm using conscious
knowledge right now to speak in words
and you are hearing me in words and
Concepts and we are engaging in this
space and our world today is completely
built on conscious knowledge in ways um
the other form is real knowledge which
is uh an immediate knowing uh inherent
in all human beings that's not the
product of knowledge um other ways you
can think about is wisdom uh you may
have heard things like trust your gut uh
creativity these this flow that comes in
from a place deeper a much Place deeper
than the mind and the rational mind and
so our world today um is very much
unbalanced towards conscious knowledge
and quite unbalanced and not enough real
knowledge and so according to cos this
cosmology we want to be right in that
Center that Fusion that beautiful Fusion
that is one or the other you are still
living here in this material plane that
we can see and interact and hear yet we
are able to draw on this wisdom from
this Web of Life from which we can start
to create completely new ways of
economies new ways of exchanging
information new ways of exchanging value
that today seem radical that today seem
unimaginable yet we are able to draw on
this
power
[Music]
um because let's face it we've all been
uh you know trained on this Dark Forest
world of information we've all been
trained from institutions and systems
the very institutions and systems that
this crypto world seems to want to to to
take to take on seems to want to
transform seems to want to change yet we
are part of these systems and so we have
to undo our very programming the very
conditioning of our mind in order to
transcend these very systems that we
want to change and so for me I see
spirituality is very embodied form of
decentralization
each of us have to do the proof of work
uh we've got to do the Mind training
we've got to do the healing we've got to
do the heart opening no one is going to
do it for you even though we as a
collective can all support each other we
each need to do that work um each of us
are interconnected nodes in this Web of
Life there is no one bigger stronger
than the other we are all part of this
web of life together and so we all
support each other and we can all
connect to each other and if we want to
create this infinite Garden we have to
feel that we can't get the Power from
Just this space of disconnection we have
to reconnect to this web of life we have
to pull this energy that exists all
around us that we're supported from from
this universe and use this information
use this energy to guide us in ways that
can really transform and push paradigms
that seem unimaginable today but in the
next moment it's possible um a couple
projects that I think are interesting um
Pagoda is a network within the ethereum
space um of Asian Southeast Asian and
East Asian uh Community Builders which
I'm a part of and we've been trying to
build how do we take these practices of
um Asian philosophy into embodied
practice how do we build technology
while also better reconnecting to life
around us to each other what does it
mean to practice what does it mean to do
that work that I mentioned the proof of
work together and how do we start to
build from there and um so a reflection
question that I'd like to sort of post
to you is how does the crypto World make
you feel connected to life uh and
there's you may find different answers
for yourself and and it's it's wonderful
to think about is how what are the ways
that the technology that I use the
crypto that I use make me feel more
fulfilled more content and what are the
ways that it makes me feel more
disconnected what are the ways where it
makes me feel more alienated more
frustrated more angry and through these
Reflections we can start to think we can
start to have conversations around what
is it that we're building how is it that
it's actually improving or changing or
making me feel more connected and
perhaps start to make changes in our own
lives and in the decisions we make many
of you here are Builders might be
investors users consumers husbands
daughters sons all of you play roles
many identities in your lives and how
can we start to use technology to ways
that make us more connected to this Web
of Life um perhaps we can start to then
think about what it means to m a
metaverse um in Buddhism meta is love
and kindness uh this idea that we can
build this metaverse which is infused
with love and kindness and respect for
life around us which can go beyond just
empty words buzzword if you will our
world is no short of Buzz words but
again it's going back this embodied
practice of how can I every day moment
to moment start to think about um what
is is it that I'm Who Am I who is it
that I'm helping how am I being being
more kind to people around me and what
kind of energy do I feel when I actually
help people in different ways and how
can I start to feel into that energy
even
more um so some of the projects that I
I'm building today that are hoping to
sort of create this alignment between uh
spirituality and technology and crypto
um light Forest is a project I've
created um working with the kernel
community at the start of the year to
thinking about how do we bring more
light into how we regenerate how do we
start to do these inner journeys of
healing yet also start to imagine create
radically new technology systems um with
thex in shangai where I'm based uh I'm
cre we're creating a culture of
conscious stewardship uh towards more
connection to have digital Nomads like
many of us here today be more connected
to the Earth to the land the soil that
we're touching to be more connected to
communities around us yet be dis yet be
hyperconnected to the to the world and
have the sense of global Consciousness
because we are living in a unique moment
where we truly have this Global identity
um and so how do we harness This Global
identity in a space while also being
feeling extremely local and grounded
into the Earth and Pagoda which I just
mentioned what we're thinking about how
do we rewi web 3 um how do we bring
Asian values and a protocol of being
that all of us can bring into our daily
lives bring into our practice and start
to really build these new worlds um so I
would love to uh you know continue these
conversations with all of you um all of
you are doing a no doubt really amazing
beautiful work uh I think all of you are
motivated towards creating these new
spaces towards creating new systems and
I think we are at this time right now
when I think the future of spirituality
and the future of this is is no longer
centralized it's not about going to a
temple or a church or it's not about
going to one leader it's actually about
feeling into the power that we all have
and learning how to harness that and
through that we can start to guide this
regeneration and building this infinite
Garden uh that ethereum and many other
communities here want to build um so
with that I'll end uh with this uh one
of my favorite quotes uh from a Buddhist
monk tikn Natan um we hear a lot about
the future uh often times these in these
spaces it's completely futur driven but
sometimes it's important to ground in
the present and to feel that
if we in every moment can be truly
grounded to be truly present and make
each moment that we're in better to make
focus on this moment and what you can
act the future itself will emerge as a
reflection of that so I'll leave you
with that thank you very much and I
think we have a couple of moments for
[Applause]
questions amazing thank you so much Lis
for all all this knowledge and okay
who's ready to asking questions I
haven't seen any question yet on the on
the Cure place we can have conversations
whether this form of technology is
keeping us more connected or
disconnected I think I see a question
there a hand raised there okay we have a
raised hand
here just one second they are coming to
you
um hi um I really enjoy your your talk
um what I would like to know it's you
recommend some books or papers maybe to
I mean to deep I mean to dive into this
uh kind of
topics yeah um there's there's a lot um
if you want to be on more academic side
some of the books that I flashed in my
slides and I can sort of share that with
you after as well uh talk about the
systemic issues um I think from a techn
front Chinese Cosmo Technics by UK is a
great very philosophical
conceptualization uh but from a more
practical sense uh in terms of practices
um there are books from tikn Natan the
monk that I flashed um from um other
Scholars as well who are who have sort
of uh on the sort of practice in being
uh but there's a lot and um also on my
website light
forest.org anyone here thank
you and the website is light forest.
World hi Dave
hi um matali here my question for you
was that you know our relationship with
money the way money looks feels Etc has
changed over time like at some point we
had living money therefore there was a
more spiritual connection to it um and
we've reached a point where money is no
more that tangible like the spiritual
relationship we have with it has
definitely changed it's moving into a
more individual World um how do you
think say
cryptocurrency uh or the web three World
in itself could um what could be
different concepts of money that take
people back to the spiritual feeling of
it or the community feeling of it yeah
thanks for that question matali it's
it's it's a question that I struggle
with um the subject of money is
definitely something that I struggle
with personally as well what is my
relationship with money and what is it
that I want from it um I think the area
that I'm finding interesting to explore
is the space of community currencies um
and this idea of how can we create
systems that allow us to keep the value
within the community um and so if
cryptocurrencies can come in in ways
that we can allow to create value and
Share value within our community unities
um and ways where communities themselves
so Village to Village or City to city as
able to transact within with that
context that they share without having
to go into this large homogeneous system
that is the US dollar or that is some
national currency I think that can be
something that can perhaps be quite
different and perhaps allow us to yeah
to Share value within communities
differently um but I think perhaps even
further than that Paradigm shifts might
necessary for us to really capture that
spiritual connection but I think in the
more immediate to near term uh and I
know there are people experimenting with
you know radical ideas of community
currencies um and and how crypto can
play a role in that which I think might
be the more immediate near-term uh use
case thank you for
that amazing we have time for one more
question yeah hey uh great talk thanks
I'm curious to hear more about this uh
dig cnx uh project I'm just um
the concept of like connecting digital
Nomads with local folks seems really
interesting I'm just wondering how did
you go about like connecting those two
worlds bringing those two worlds did you
see participation from actual local
folks in changai and what did that look
like yeah um another good question a big
challenge that we have um so with digx
we created this about two years ago
which was to create a community that
went across web 3 and you know digital
rights activists uh academics
journalists across the board
um we actually with the popup City you
know initiative that happened in October
we started a project called Cosmo local
changai and the idea was there is to
really create spaces where we could
bring together you know local people
with global Nomads but also create
Nomads encourage a culture of you know
understanding local cultures and
practices that are there I think it's
hard uh for many reasons linguistic uh
cultural there's also a certain energy
of chai the sort of saai saai you know
that that sh culture which kind of
clashes with this heavy hitter crypto
Global you know digital Nomad you know
going and so I think it'll be a
multi-year process probably uh but I
think people there are slivers of people
who are interested in a more deeper
connection with nature and I think we're
hoping to be in that Lial space where
even small groups of people can start to
connect and we can sort of start to
create that culture of of conscious
stewardship I'm happy to chat after if
you're you know coming to changma or
base there often there thank you awesome
thank you so much leou please give him a
real big Applause thank you thank you
everyone thank you so
much okay don't leave because coming
next we have something about open music
protocol so please stay
[Music]
for
hey how is everything going coming next
we have Ray Jacobson from Aus who is
bringing an open music protocol into the
real world on boarding Millions Ray
loves mango sticky rice and he will talk
to us with that sweetness today so
please give me a warm welcome to Ray
Jacobson
[Music]
he asked me for a fun fact I really do
like mango sticky rice it's awesome um
anyway hey I'm Ray uh my talk is called
onboarding Millions if you were just
here for Dave's talk this is going to be
a very different vibe but we're going to
get down to Brass tax and we're going to
talk about how we onboard people into
the web 3 ecosystem my name is Ray I'm
the CTO TI Labs which is one of the
contributors the audius
protocol is this on
different slide oh we went too far okay
I all right I would assume that most
people here have seen these words
written before I certainly have the
internet certainly has and I think
candidly the jury is a little bit out
still on like what actually is the
killer use case for crypto and this is
my personal favorite I'll leave it on
this slide for a second if you want to
read
it so I think that crypto can probably
be all of these things but we really
need to focus on consumer and we need to
do it in a way that we really haven't
been so far so my presentation today I
want to talk to you in a few minutes
about some of the pretty hot takes I
have about the ecosystem and things that
everyone who's in the consumer space
really should be thinking
about before I get into that a little
bit of background on what audius is uh
just so you know that you can take my
words to have some amount of weight
audius is a decentralized music
streaming service that's governed and
operated by its Community web 3 music
platform why are we doing this we want
to help artists and rights holders of
Music control their Destiny online and
how do we do this we're providing direct
access between artists labels and their
fans with really deep engagement tools
and monetization tools to make it happen
at a quick glance these are some of the
stats really excited every time I show
this slide uh because a lot of these
numbers are really big and I think
there's some weight to some of the
things that I'm going to share about how
we've gotten to this point so hot take
number one I'm not going to spend a ton
of time here let's call them apps the
term D app is meaningless out there most
people in the world are still using
phones and browsers I assume most people
here are doing that until we have some
radical new hardware we should not be
using terms that alienate web 2 users
let's call them
apps number two emails are amazing and I
think we should try really hard to not
reinvent things that we don't have to
reinvent we have so many hard problems
to solve as this industry but I think
decentralized identity is not actually
one of them that we need to spend that
much more time on this is our biggest
competitor probably have seen this logo
before this is their signup form it has
one input field pretty much Universal
across the world anyone who's using a
computer knows what to do
here this is what we seem to have
adopted and if I'm a web 2 user and I
look at this I have no idea what I'm
looking at I don't know what any of
these words mean I don't know what any
of these logos are and this is almost
dead in the water from day
one what I'm proposing in this hot take
is that emails are decentralized
identity with billions of users and can
be used to make really great web 3
native onboarding and there are a lot of
products out there that do this really
well we have our own home rolled one
there are many people at this conference
who are building things like this so you
can make something like this and this is
we've spent a lot of time trying to make
our on rting process as familiar as
possible number three sometimes Fiat is
okay we should settle in crypto we
should let people custody their funds we
should provide sometimes Fiat ux show
balances in Fiat where we can we are in
a transitionary period as an industry
and we should meet users where they're
at so here's a quick case study from
aias this is an artist named ko ko on
the track is what he goes by he ran this
remix competition on audius where he
listed things you can see here it's in
dollars and cents $449.99 he made
$30,000 in Revenue in two weeks and not
a single person who purchased this track
was web 3 native but behind the scenes
everything was settled in usdc and the
thing that I want to articulate here is
that we can still get all of the perks
of programmable money without users even
knowing that they're on crypto and that
is an Incredible use case for us number
four we should stop teaching users
unnecessary things our users don't give
a if we are an L1 L2 app chain kafa
postgress like whatever it is make the
right technical decision weighing all of
these things but make a decision where
you can build ux that doesn't have to
explain this to your users at all these
are really important problems we should
be solving but they're not marketing
copy and if your signup flow has a user
pick a chain you're starting off on the
wrong foot number five and my last one
because I think my lightning talk is
almost over we should lean on some of
the Financial tools that we can that
other people can't we can do a lot more
in web 3 than in web 2 because of the
way we can do Capital formation the way
that web two users already expect many
things to be free we can put that on
steroids and give all sorts of access
that other people cannot do this whole
concept of the infinite
Garden um so really you know my pitch to
you is that you know if we're going to
onboard millions of users we should
build the best products forgetting about
web 2 web 3 whatever build the best
products we have some of the strongest
mind and Technical people in all of
Technology here if you're if you're in
oh my emoji didn't go but if you're if
you're in consumer your target audience
is not here today and we should really
really internalize that and think deeply
about it um thank you I'll take Q&A and
uh if you are interested in talking
about this more please seek me out after
uh we also are running a event on
Thursday if you like music and you want
to talk to like-minded people
too
thanks awesome right thank you so much
we have space for one question who's
going to be the lucky one
there hi my name is Nefertiti um I was
signed to Universal for like too long
and I'm wondering what's your motivation
if you're not like rooted in music to
create this type of platform for
musicians uh rooted in music is my
personal background or just in general
why do people like you make these types
of I want to go against Spotify totally
yeah um you know I mean there's there's
many stories we have of people that
we've worked with who have like yourself
signed deals sometimes that don't favor
them and and ultimately we want to give
people the opportunity to choose I
myself am a musician I grew up playing
piano from a young age played on Rock
bin in high school never pursued music
full-time because I ended up liking
software more but I think the creative
space is one of the like ripe fruits to
pick in this new wave of Technology
where there can to be a lot of impact on
ownership and I think that's like the
the perfect marriage with something like
music
um would love to talk talk more though
and a few folks from our team are here
as
well okay thank you so much please give
an Applause to Ray appreciate that man
thank you there thank you so much so
please the people around you can find
sits here in the front so just a minute
before we go with the next talk
[Music]
hey
everyone coming next with we have Julian
net who is going to talk about something
that is really really important for
ethereum and it's how to use account
exraction tool to get to many more
people so bringing ethereum to 1 billion
telegram users with Julian n please
receive B with a warm
[Music]
welcome so hi my name is Julian as
introduced I'm one of the three
co-founder at arjon and today I want to
talk about how we can bring ethereum to
1 billion telegram users I know this is
kind of a cliche title and we've been
talking about onboarding millions or
billions of users for for many years but
hopefully I'll convince that no we can
actually do
so and and yes it's kind of funny that
we talk about the billion users why the
reality is very very different if we
look at the amount of daily active users
of popular defi application we see it
that you know we make a few thousand
daily active users on na for example we
can zoom a bit more and look at some
popular blockchains of the ethereum
ecosystem and we see that you know
arbitr L1 they do half a million daily
active users Bas has been on a good role
lately doing on average 1 million daily
active users but we are still very very
far for the from this 1 billion and
what's interesting is that if we keep
zooming out a bit more and start looking
outside of the eum ecosystem we might
notice that there's something happening
on ton a single T to earn game on turn
called armster combat average 30 million
daily active users we not talking about
the blockchain that's a single game but
what I do find fascinating about arate
combat is that it actually reached these
crazy numbers in three months we've been
building theer system for almost 10
years uh yet a single game on turn is
reaching 250 million users in three
months so the question is what's the
catch what's the trick you may think
that ton is such an amazing blockchain
that you know millions of viewers are
rushing to using it I don't believe this
is the case what I think is that the
secret source is actually telegram
itself and it kind of makes sense when
you think of it telegram is actually an
amazing distribution channel it's one of
the largest social network with 950
million monthly active users we're
talking about bringing a billion users
to ethereum there you go that's your
billion because it's a social network it
has social EnV virality features baked
in right you have butt you have
messaging group group chat and so on and
I think that's the reason why these
games on on turn they manage to reach
crazy numbers so rapidly something that
a lot of people don't realize but
telegram is actually very
crypto-friendly it already has an you
know an existing web to ecosystem I
mentioned you know gaming telegram mini
apps on turn but you also have some kind
of Def ecosystem on salana with trading
buts averaging something like 60 million
dollars per day and finally one thing
one last thing that I think is important
is the fact also that on telegram every
single user is already logged in so you
have a platform of a billion users that
you can actually already
know so I've mentioned telegram mini
apps I'm sure many of you know what they
are but still just to so we are all on
the same page a telegram minap is
basically a full-fledged web application
that runs inside telegram they build
with the normal Tex stack and they have
access to some cool technical features
for example if your phone enables it
they have access to biometric and a
secure and cl
they can have access to the telegram clo
storage they've been available since
2023 uh but what's fascinating is that
they've been really built for the web3
ecosystem and that shouldn't be
underestimated so telegram Min apps are
part of telegram strategy to actually
bring the users to
T and of course they've been fueling the
growth of the ton Network so the
question is can we bring these 1 billion
users to ethereum instead of ton and I
believe the answer is yes we can really
build and I hope I show you that in the
remaining time of this talk we can build
the perfect invisible non-custodial
wallet for these 1 billion
users and why do I say that I do believe
we have two casts that we can play to
our advantage the first one is that we
we have now ler two. scale for example
Stark net achieved 867 transaction per
second a couple of weeks ago and we know
they will double or triple that in a few
months with something called Kon native
so we have layer tools that can actually
support 1 billion users but we Al also
have something that is fascinating is
that abstraction today for example at
arjon we have session keys in production
we have social recovery in production we
have pay masters in
production and so using that we can
build a platform for user and for
developers so we've built a wallet a
telegram mini app wallet and there's a
few things that are very interesting the
first thing is that there's no on
boarding required that's really cool we
can use biometric and you have the
typical Argent model but what's even
more interesting is that using a wallet
you can send token to anyone on telegram
even if they don't have a wallet so you
can pick one of your friend a telegram
contact and you can send them for
example usdc and because we've we have
integrated a pay master that friend can
be onboarded in a second and use this
usdc directly so now we have a solution
to bring people from not knowing what
web3 is to having a funded web3 wallet
that they can use directly in just one
click as I've mentioned we've also built
a SDK for dap and the the goal of this
SDK is really to Leverage What something
that's called session Keys unfortunately
I won't have the time to explain what
they are but they really enable mini
dabs to build an experience where the
wallet has become completely
invisible and so this is for example the
example of a of a game oops
sorry of a game being built on Stark net
CL gladi appet hopefully I'll be able to
make that work no
sorry this is not going to work so I'll
just explain what it was supposed to
show so basically it's a game telegram
mini app what's fascinating is that as a
user when you click connect connect your
wallet or connect your account like in
web 2 What happen is that the wallet
pops out tells you the authorization
it's requiring as the user you say Okay
approve the wallet disappears and now
you can play the game for a month and
the game can make transaction on your
account they are secured because of
session keys so for a month as a user
you never see the wallet again so we
really enable a webt like experience but
fully on web 3 with a noncustodial
custodial wallet and so unfortunately I
wasn't able to show you the demo but I I
really believe we have built an
invisible non-custodial wallet on the
layer two that scales so now it's really
time to finally on board these one
billion users to ethereum thank
you thank you so much that was amazing
Julian do we have a question we have
space for just one question
so who's going to be the lucky
one no question it's everything clear
okay here
please all right hello thank you J for
amazing talk uh could you please uh
explain to me to the audience uh how
like the new users that you're talking
about like the people that don't have
any wallets the people that uh you will
be sending money to even though they've
never even established anything uh
beforehand how would they uh like like
my grandma or someone how would she then
convert it to
Fiat to Fiat afterwards yes well I would
say that's a question that the scope is
outside of the wallet that's a general
question how to offr from you know from
from crypto here what we are focusing is
first of all onboarding people to crypto
we're not yet focusing about on on
offboarding them well what we want to
achieve is
really bringing all these people to
having a funded web three wallet and
today because today your grandma I mean
it's important for her to go to from
crypto to Fiat but we are also trying to
build an ecosystem on chain an ecosystem
on stable Co so I I think we should
first focus on trying to onboard these
people and and what we've shown here is
that we can really on board these people
in One Click because what would happen
in practice is that you for example you
want to you can send with our wallet you
can send 10 US SDC to your grandmother
and the way it will appear to her it
will be basically just a claiming link
on the direct you know the the the
private discussion you have with your
grandmother on telegram she will click
on that link and because there's no on
onboarding on our wallet the wallet will
pop up and automatically it will be
funded with the token that you have
Center and because we're using something
like a pay Master she will be able to
pay transaction fees with this usdc so
that means in one click she has a wallet
that she can use to either send some
usdc to one of your brother or one of
your cousin or maybe she'll be able to
use this usdc to pay for a coffee in a
shop or just to play a game so to answer
your question for the moment we're not
focusing about the offr problem we
really want first to bring these users
and being able to action them in
basically one
click thank you thank you thank you
okay awesome thank you so much people in
the back we have seats here in the front
waiting for you so you can come
closer coming next we
have yeah it's a good question who needs
a wallet anyway after what we saw so
with us we have itai turbah today please
give him a warm
[Music]
welcome shall we do it hey everyone
how's it going good bad terrible
everything good okay so I'm itai uh
co-founder of dynamic and what I want to
talk to you guys today about is pretty
much who needs a w anyway uh just a
raise of hands who has heard a wallet
talk today before uh before my talk or
is this the first talk of wallets anyway
no okay so let's start so uh a little
bit about me and Shameless plug so I'm
the co-founder and CEO of dynamic uh we
essentially do uh everything that has to
do with email login social login wallet
login on a site so when you click log in
uh if you go to magic Eden today or
Doodles or pudgy penguins and you click
log in that's that's probably powered by
Dynamic uh we help you build crypto
enabled experiences but uh that's pretty
much all I'll kind of shamelessly plug
about dynamic again we're we're powering
a bunch of these popular apps um that's
just context for why I'm talking about
this topic which is the topic of wallets
or abstraction of those wallets uh so
let's get to it so uh at the very basic
level the web is moving to a wallet
based world right if you open your phone
in five years and look at every app on
your phone it's likely going to have a
wallet component to it it's a very
effective way to transfer money to
transfer assets to kind of control
identity is it's a really really cool
way and what we're seeing is that we're
starting to see apps on your phone not
new apps but existing apps have wallet
components to them but users don't
really care about wallets no one wakes
up in the morning and says I really want
a wallet right you want these like
magical experiences and when they're
crypto enabled you kind of need a wallet
uh to enable them wallets are not the
star of the show it pains me to say as a
wallet company but we are not the stars
of the show we're pretty much kind of in
the background infrastru structure and
so the way to think about wallets is
really um in an analogy of thinking
about um crypto is the electric grid as
power and everyone wants to kind of hook
up to power uh wallets are really
outlets in your wall we're in the
business of selling Outlets to you and
those uh no one kind of cares about
Outlets Outlets are not kind of the
thing you buy uh for the sake of buying
Outlets you buy them because you want to
plug in your TV and watch TV or you want
to plug in your laptop and of play games
right so wallets aren't the the main
part of the show so why are we putting
wallets front and center today why are
there so many branded wallets why are we
even talking about them and the answer
is is we shouldn't right people don't
care maybe folks in this room do but but
anyone else doesn't really care about
wallets right and that's exactly what
we're seeing in this market and so what
I want to show you is two examples of
companies that are abstracting away
wallets and deferring that to later on
in the process and focus f using on
building these magical consumer
experiences where wallets don't kind of
come up front and center where you don't
log in with a wallet first and one
example and let's see if this video
works oh I actually did okay that's uh
that's great uh so this is a company
called deflow and uh it lets you trade
pretty much anything you want you log in
with email you enter your passcode and
at that point you're done right so we'll
see whether this enters it bear me for a
second oh okay great uh the video
actually works so I entered an email I
logged in and I'm done at this point I
have a wallet I can kind of export my
private key it's a non-custodial wallet
uh I can trade but I really don't need
to care about the fact that I have a
wallet it's my way of accessing crypto
Without Really knowing it's crypto in
the same example there's a really cool
app out there let's see if this works be
me for a second it actually did called
bags who's used bags before love it okay
so it's a really cool app uh the idea is
again it's a trading app in this case a
meme trading app you can buy memes you
can kind of chat but you shouldn't
really care about the fact that you have
a wallet it's just a means to an end
right but the challenge with that and
the challenge with what I've shown is
that we're while we're seeing this daily
across everything whether it's deepin or
rwa Etc the challenge is that it kind of
optimizes for local Maxima right it
optimizes for we're going to have
hundreds of wallets right we solve the
new user onboarding problem but we don't
solve the interoperability problem right
we optimize um kind of each one of these
app optimizes for them it doesn't
optimize for kind of a global really
nice hey everything is in single wallet
but we can actually optimize and this is
the only technical slide apologies but
my point here is to say that everything
we're seeing in this market everything
that we're seeing with hundreds of these
wallets be generated across these apps
that's totally fine because what will
happen is providers like us and others
will start thinking about ways to let
you aggregate those across different
kind of apps right so you start with a
local Maxima you start by kind of
letting someone accomplish what they
want to accomplish and then you start
building tools to let them aggregate uh
these magical wallets and so I'm
actually good on time which is
surprising uh but my main takeaway from
this talk and I know it's a very quick
talk but my main takeaway if you take
nothing else away is as you see these
embedded wallets as you see these
hundreds of apps or thousands of new
social apps or defi apps or dpin apps
come up and they don't talk about
wallets and you're worried about hey I'm
going to start having these hundreds of
wallets with all my assets distributed
across them in my pocket know that it's
fine it's a step in the path to kind of
these Global decentralization type um
standards and not all hope is lost so
what we'll see in a couple years is
we'll see these kind of apps cons excuse
me consolidate into this kind of magical
branded wallets that let you kind of
connect these small accounts that you
generated into ger ones so the future is
not lost uh hopefully everyone comes out
of this kind of encouraged that it's a
step abstracting way wallets is a step
towards kind of a really nice crypto
future without jeopardizing onboarding
experience in the short term and with
that uh if anyone wants to talk to me
about it if anyone wants to tell me I
have no idea what I'm talking about just
here's my telegram sping me you can
email me at it dynamic. XYZ and I would
love to take questions
awesome thank you so much man who's got
a question who's got a question for e at
this moment we have just room for one
question so who's going to be the lucky
one going once here please go for
it sorry what are the security concerns
with this parent child wallet
relationship yeah the short answer is a
bunch right uh the longer answer is that
not all your wallets actually need to be
connected over time right we we think
about this connection of parent child
and kind of a general account and sub
account as as required to create the
single identity but we're actually
creatures of multiple identities right I
have my identity at home with my kids I
have my identity at work I have my
gaming identity I have my social
identity and they're different and you
might actually not have this one parent
child but you might have multiple
parents depending on your identity so
that's one way to Der risk it uh the
second is about controls just like
everything else here right it's about uh
uh the beauty of optionality right which
is at times it's you can oneclick on
link you can oneclick link you can
consolidate your assets you can break
them up and so it's about optionality
and kind of the ability for you to
create multiple identities that kind of
lower the security risk but the short
answer to your question is just like
anything else when you combine multiple
wallets into a single place you create
some security
risk and I think that's all the time we
had right uh how am I doing one more
question one quick question do you pass
there's one in the thing oh okay oh yeah
go for it or I I'll ask the question do
you pass key
Integrations okay I'm gonna make a bet
on what this question means uh do we
offer Pass Key integration the answer is
yes we do uh whether that was the
question or not I don't care but like
the answer I want to give is yes we do
we actually offer pasy Integrations uh
pasis are in general this like really
magical thing because they're a private
public key on your phone and they
inherit some really cool properties with
companies like Google and apple that
while we sometimes don't like they kind
of have to deal with security to your
point at the state actor level and so
they really have to think about this
stuff at really massive scale and pasis
are one of the outputs of that thinking
and so yes we specifically offer pasy
Integrations I'm sure others within our
industry do as well they're a really
powerful Tool uh to actually get to this
both non- custody or self custody uh as
well as create this experience that at
least on mobile feels very native uh
which is a face ID type experience so
yes short answer is yes thank you so
much it that was fantastic please give
me a great Applause thanks everyone
appreciate
and coming next we
have inion achieving system qualities
through design
choices one one reminder please don't
forget to scan the QR code to ask your
questions you can write your questions
while he's going to be talking and then
we can uh read your questions so please
give a warm welcome to Orin
McMillan thank
[Music]
you all right hey folks I'm Laurin I'm
gonna stand over here so I can see my
notes
maybe there we go uh so I'm going to
talk briefly today just about uh
building with intention I'm not going to
do intros and everything because got
five minutes and just want to quickly
kind of wrap through everything um so
when I say building with intention what
I really mean here is being deliberate
about uh the combination of tools and uh
components that we use to construct
systems in order to achieve specific
qualities um and a critically overlooked
part of this is understanding what
qualities one actually wants to achieve
in a system one is designing uh so in
your designing systems uh perhaps the
best shortcut I can offer for actually
understanding what qualities you might
need um is to mentally stray from the
happy path uh so the default way that we
typically think about building
applications uh and systems is to
consider the the affordances the
features that we want to enable but a
lot of our most critical design choices
often don't make themselves apparent
until we uh either mentally Traverse the
kind of unhappy paths uh what happens
when something goes wrong uh or they
reveal themselves later uh they reveal
themselves to kind of be critically
absent when it's already too late um so
it's it's this category of problems that
we're typically trying to solve for Via
decentralization but in our industry I
think uh decentralization is this kind
of buzzword right it's it's this
commonplace descriptor expectation but
it's near meaningless in a lot of cases
um because it's treated as an end uh and
in reality it's a means it's a means to
achieving a handful of other qualities
that are really valuable in in uh the
types of systems that we're often
building uh and so I want to quickly
caveat that decentralization is this
kind of spectrum it's not binary a
system may be more or less decentralized
than another system
across various different axes and most
complex systems make these really
explicit kind of trade-offs at various
layers of their stack based on which
priorities or which which resistance is
essentially asking the question can one
prohibit another from using the system
uh and if so under what
[Music]
more decentralized Twitter Alternatives
uh things like fasta to aim to find
essentially a different balance
between uh this censorship resistance
and then content moderation playing uh
next one correct execution uh will the
system essentially behave as expected
could one coers the system into
unexpected behavior um a good kind of
example here would be thinking about say
airline miles right you would expect to
uh earn Miles when you fly be able to
redeem them to purchas a flight um but
those things could be arbitrarily
changed right um
by by whoever's operating the the
airline miles and unfortunately we've
had a kind of trend towards similar
patterns recently in uh in the web3
space uh essentially treating uh points
right uh these arbitrary arbitrarily
kind of controlled systems for for end
up reintroducing some uh censorship or
capture resistance or or correct
execution uh vectors uh last one here
sorry availability uh essentially can
one rely on the system to to to be
online uh is the system dependent on any
specific actors uh and what happens if
they're unavailable um obviously the the
the previous two correct exe uh yeah
correct execution and censorship
resistant are kind of subsets of or or
kind of tightly related to
availability um but yeah another another
kind of really important quality and
then this last quality here uh capture
resistance is essentially asking like
will the other guarantees hold
indefinitely is there some party that
could uh could arbitrarily change these
rules in future or or kind of capture
enough of the the mechanisms that
control this thing to make changes in
future
um so again these the these four kind of
key qualities censorship resistance uh
correct execution availability and
capture resistance uh in
concert uh these are kind of best
achieved via radical
decentralization um however obviously
legitimate decentralization is is
notoriously difficult to achieve um and
this is the whole kind of value
proposition for the infinite Garden for
for blockchains like ethereum is to
enable applications to inherit these
kind of features uh while focusing on
implementing their own affordances um so
I guess yeah the the kind of key
question here that I'd encourage people
to ask is when they're designing systems
is what qualities what of these
qualities can they inherit from uh the
systems that they're building on top of
um and which qualities do they need to
kind of explicitly engineer uh and then
kind of importantly are any of the
design choices they're making about or
you're making about the systems You're
Building uh undermining the qualities
that you would otherwise inherit um
again you can you can largely inherit
those four qualities from building on
top of something like ethereum but it's
it's very easy to unintentionally or
intentionally undermine them and kind of
reintroduce some of the problems uh so
I'll leave it there for today
necessarily super high level very quick
talk uh happy to go deeper into the
topic if anyone wants to chat again
uh but just to reiterate big takeaways
uh is really important to tread that on
Happy path when you're designing systems
uh think about the things that could go
wrong how your system handles it what
you uh what
what qualities you can uh uh bake into
your system in order to to avoid those
unhappy paths or handle those unhappy
paths um from those that have kind of
trodden the unhappy paths before us a
handful of the really critically
important qualities censorship
resistance correct execution
availability and capture resistance uh
and then obviously you can inherit those
qualities by building on top of ethereum
or something like ethereum um but be
careful not to undermine them uh you can
find me on Twitter at Orin McMillan
thanks for the uh very brief
[Applause]
talk awesome Morin we have time for one
question who who wants to who wants to
go next with a
question someone
just just one question not that many
hints just we have space for one
question cool everything clear Orin how
you you you mentioned the role to um
well let's just say full
decentralization that it's quite far um
what do you think like if you give us
like a time
frame oh so I'm notar saying like a road
to full decentralization I'm saying if
you're building uh a a system from
scratch it's it's very difficult to to
build a legitimately decentralized
system largely because it it implies
having uh cultivating a community of say
node operators right and this is a this
is a notoriously difficult thing to do
is to to set up the incentive structure
and uh and actually find rally the
people to kind of run your nodes or or
kind of participate in your ecosystem
and do you knows that
are and do you know any projects that
are um that have that standard that
you're looking at there ethereum it's
great so like this is a great way to to
inherit a bunch of these qualities is is
by deploying on ethereum or deploying on
uh something that's that's kind of tied
to
ethereum thank you so much everyone
please give him a great Applause I
appreciate it thanks folks thank you
[Music]
okay awesome coming next we have a
discussion panel about a strategies on
do you really know your web tree users
please give um Applause to Alice
[Music]
shabro Austin
kibble Rahul
rumala and Romina
[Applause]
buo thank you so much everyone please go
ahead and thank you everyone for staying
here all this
session okay check can you guys hear me
okay sa C Bangkok Welcome to our talk or
panel uh super excited to be here thank
you for uh thank you to ethereum
Foundation Devcon for having us first of
all so we are going to take the next 45
minutes to uh talk about some some of
the topics that we feel super passionate
about which is data privacy user privacy
just users and product in general so
with that uh I just want to introduce
myself my name is Rahul uh I've been in
crypto for a while I'm at currently VP
at safe uh leading product engineering
and uh today we are essentially with
these three talented individuals which I
will let them introduce themselves so
first uh I hand it off to Romina yeah hi
Romina Bal is my name I'm founder of
Capital we are an onchain risk and
investment management firm um yeah I've
been in this bace since 2017 and mostly
building on the capital market and
institutional
side all right hi everyone I'm Austin uh
designer at Dune um we have another
designer in the audience here at Dune uh
thank you for joining um been in the
space for a while been designing uh in
the space since around 2020 um and
hanging out as a participant before that
so
and hi um I'm Alice I'm a data analyst
at safe I work with the product team to
help them understand their users build
features that respond to user needs and
evaluate the impact of new features that
we
launch um and I've been in a space for
about a couple years and before that I
was working um for the UK government
with policy designers and also product
designers to do exactly the same thing
building for users and citizens
so are you all ready to talk about users
and data and privacy and all that
shebang let's go let's go let's go all
right so firstly I just want to set some
context right uh uh so product Discovery
we call this a process you know to
understand users problems and using that
knowledge to build uh the product so in
the world of web 3 where things like
anonymity and privacy Prevail the
question is that how can teams identify
user problems user segments and collect
the right data so to understand their
behaviors so as we I mean we heard this
a lot today as we aim to uh onboard the
next billion uh web3 users so the
question really becomes how should we
balance building user Centric products
in a privacy Centric ecosystem and with
this panel we hope to accomplish
touching on some of those uh points so
just set the first question uh I want to
set another context here it's been uh 10
years uh since uh Devcon zero which
started in uh ksb Berlin uh right where
Romina and I are from for example uh a
lot has changed uh lot of new products
lot of new problems lot of new users and
uh opportunities as well and uh so it's
it's super nice to see how things have
changed and put that into context right
so kind of like let's have a little bit
of an icebreaker uh just to kind of get
the discussions going right
uh so this is a question for all of you
all uh what type of a crypto user are
you and what is your current
relationship with
privacy okay I can start so I think I
come from more like from the defi side
um alsoo for my personal uses so I'm not
so much um using the social aspect of uh
the projects uh that have been built but
I for example organize my wallets like I
have one hot wallet that is basically my
avatar or it's connected to my Twitter
handle. e and uh this is basically where
I hold just like some assets so I can
pay with D or Stables just like I always
have like 100 or 200 in some stable
coins have some nfts and maybe also some
um additional e for for gas fees um so
this is the the one that I want to use
for non-sensitive interactions it's also
public right like people that know my
Twitter name they can look it up so I'm
aware about that so for um my business
activities I then have a signer just to
sign transactions in the companies for
example with the multi setup so it
always has like a signature deficit um
it manages a lot of transactions they
are sensitive um but there is there are
no assets held on this um it's also nice
for me to keep my tax accounting
overhead low because I can basically do
my tax filings just like with one CSV
download and then it's more convenient
for me and then for all the other assets
or my portfolio composition and I have
like a dedicated e wallet or I have a
wallet on another chain and I yeah
basically have a little exell list to
keep keep an overview of uh my wallets
that are also segregated and there are
also so funded sometimes from accounts
that are not directly connected to my
avatar address so there is like my
personal privacy approach but it's not a
technical
solution all right so I think that
there's different buckets uh in the
space I mean you have your privacy
purists maybe your wallet Wanderers who
are willing to just connect willy-nilly
um and then may be in the midd middle uh
utility Seekers I think I'm a utility
Seeker so if I see that I can get some
clear value from something I'm like
happy to to connect and share and in
general just in general uh you know I
think um I'm I'm Pro transparency um but
also when it comes to kind of financial
activity I guess I was brought up not to
really talk about money so it's strange
to initiate a digital conversation with
your like of I guess like Financial
history uh so maybe uh yeah what Romina
mentions kind of resonates on that front
um but uh but yeah I think what really
inspired me to get into to the space was
ownership in the end um I saw that
creative people could uh to have could
have ownership you could have more
people on cap tables actually owning
parts of projects and businesses so
that's what inspired me to get into the
space but I think there has to be that
value exchange so I'd say I'm a utility
Seeker I'm willing to uh that's kind of
my take on privacy I'm happy to to
commit information if I feel if I
understand the value exchange there
so that that's quite well put I'd say
I'm a utility Seeker on that point um as
a crypto user I'm probably one of your
inactive users uh I'm one that puts
money in but never takes money out or
doesn't actually really engage with all
the products that we have out there just
because I still feel like the learning
curve is too big to invest and I don't
have the patience so I put money in I
don't take it out um I don't really do
transactions um from a privacy point of
view my personal privacy I feel like
I've not really thought about I feel
like I was born in the internet age and
I don't really care how people use my
data I just say that's the world we live
in and I've I've got to that's the
trade-off I make for the convenience
that I get but as a data analyst
especially coming from government I care
very much about how the company that I
work with leverages the data of our
users so I'm very privacy focused when
it comes to our users um not so much my
data yeah that's all is super
interesting because we have like very
different personas of how we use and
what type of user you are so I think
it's kind of like a excellent stage for
the next question which I want to ask
Romina uh as someone who's been in the
industry for uh quite quite a long time
how do you feel like the users of our
industry has changed over the years and
how has this affected uh the the
industry in general yeah so at the
beginning there was obviously many
infrastructure
um or um tech for managing our
interactions missing so at the beginning
there was safe wasn't around yet right
there was multi6 Solutions have just
started to be built so uh my first
wallet was uh my ether wallet um and um
yeah it was very cumbersome you had to
basically write down every every step of
how you would interact or to to keep an
overview so do you ex um has been um
massively upgraded I think we actually
also sometimes have better ux for
certain aspects when we think about our
websites or you know like the the when
we connect our wallets all that part I
find is great but um yeah so we saw the
shift from a rather developer focused ux
or also the design Styles so some
projects you still see that they use
Font Styles like you would have in a
coding terminal
or just like they also design their
products how a terminal is structured
for example but you see that less and
less and projects sometimes uh pivot a
bit their um ux designs or the flows
tailored to their users when they got
learned more about them over the course
of the time but some projects are also
kind of dogmatic and stick to a rather
cumbersome
ux uh one that were was um keeping quite
attached uh to their terrible um '90s ux
was cury at the beginning um I guess
many of you remember it basically looked
like Windows uh
95 um yeah but then there were for
example nft minting cream experiences
where you could like with a mini
computer set like the features of the
nft or the Avatar you wanted to meit so
you could basically set the Met data
function and then the metadata was then
giving you for example a feature card of
the Avatar or the Persona that you have
been mined and that was amazing so there
have been some great Solutions pioneered
now we just need them to be adopted in
the big apps or um yeah chains that we
are using yeah so I think that's that's
interesting and uh also like I remember
uh the last time uh I was in uh Devcon
Prague for example I was building my
first company and I was talking to the
users there you know like just asking
how should we build this and uh one of
the feedbacks I have received is uh that
uh if you're building in crypto you
should be building for crypto users
first so let that sync it right like
that was the a very maximalist belief
back maybe in 2016 2017 I wouldn't say
it's probably like widespread but it was
a very strong belief so maybe like Alice
Austin you all have been in the maybe
for 3 four years I would say as a user
how does that perspective make you all
feel like how did you all experience the
same was it still the same when you
entered and has that
changed yeah sure
um I would totally agree with this I
think if you're building for crypto and
you want to gain user adoption then
you've got to build things that are
built on say account abstraction but
without using that term you know if
you're if you're doing account
abstraction the right way the truth is
your user won't know that it's built on
account abstraction they won't even know
that it's built on web 3 they might not
even know there's digital assets
powering it and we're seeing this with
things like poly Market or worldcoin
those are the real apps that are gaining
traction and that are actually on
boarding users today um but
without being you wouldn't they wouldn't
call themselves crypto users or web
three users necessarily and it's just un
blocking a lot of use cases that you
don't see anywhere
else yeah to follow up on that um I
think at the beginning so I've been a
participant in the space I guess for
maybe seven years something like that
and then just designing for the past
three or four um so I've seen a little
bit of the evolution not like super OG
but I think at first it was the secret
club and the language that we use I'm
appreciate Romina talking about like
even the design and the aesthetic um uh
but the language that we use both the
visual language and the written language
um was kind of exclusive like we wanted
it to be this secret handshake Club I I
think that's actually fine early on so
when you heard this comment I think uh
it might have been that might have been
fine for the time you know you you were
solving super hard problems um around
like decentralization and privacy and
cryptography and now a lot of that is
table stakes and it's time to to grow
and to like communicate not only
internally but like externally um
and the good news I I mean I have a lot
of critiques maybe we're not doing this
enough um but we are seeing like real
use cases like my in-law family in
Argentina um I mean they're all over
like stable coins and it's very common
practice I just had um uh a friend from
Argentina like put put a down payment on
a house uh using you know crypto um and
they're like how you know like uh C like
Exchange locations you know because you
need to put all the money up front
because you don't have like
sophisticated financing options a lot of
times so it's you know I think that we
are like solving very at first it was
very abstract but now I think we're
solving very core like human problems so
stability for example like why do people
want stable coins well like Argentina
experienced over 200% inflation you
can't plan for the future you can't save
you can't you know make plans for your
family and so and it's not about making
money it's just like keeping money right
and so I think that's why some of the
stuff we're making is really taking off
and um it's a testament to some of these
secret handshakes early on you know like
some of this like secret club stuff like
they you know solving really difficult
problems and now I think we can have
more Nuance takes on privacy for example
with zero knowledge proofs and um you
know but I think it is time to to
develop like a a more I guess I guess
like a just a I just just to talk to
more people and um that is one thing
that I haven't been doing for that long
so I can't take credit for the design
but I like that I feel like they they're
trying to speak to more people um and
there's some other really great projects
out there too if I can connect to what
you just said you mentioned um the the
users in countries like Argentina for
example and stable coin interactions um
so here when we think about yeah should
you cater this dogmatism about yeah
should you cater to crypto native users
first and then yeah they there you have
like these certain ux designs that are
Maybe crypto Anarchist inspired and it
was it's actually intentional right um
and those approaches like cater to
Crypton native maybe first was true for
projects like safe right for example
safe has grown and has adopted by now we
have like swap um Solutions natively
integrated the user doesn't even have to
know that um he has to look it up on the
web on Google for example if he wants to
trade on cowap he will get it selected
or in an interface nicely presented and
safe um but there are also use cases
like when we want to cater to these
people in Emerging Markets where some
solutions didn't work and now CEO for
example has um great traction with um
catering crypto users and um these are
basically telephone or mobile phone
users that get a crypto wallet spun up
um connected to their telephone that
they have or their mobile device um and
they're not even aware that they're
using the blockchain um so there's this
partnership mini pay together with Oprah
and I think these are great designs so
it's a very different approach than
catering to crypto native users first
and then learn and adopt so depending on
what your use case is your approach
could look very different so knowing
your user well or like where your
solution has the high impact I think
should um yeah give you the orientation
on which approach you
follow I thought the quote said the
opposite I thought you said if you want
to build for crypto you should not build
for crypto users which is what what I
believe is what we should do um that's
true so I think it's about knowing your
users but it's also about knowing your
potential users right because if we just
rehash what do we know about our web
three users today and what are they
doing and how are they interacting on
chain we're missing all the other aspect
and then you know not even thinking
about what are the users that are not
currently on chain doing and what is the
purpose for bringing them on chain so so
that's an interesting segue right like
uh knowing uh the users and knowing what
the users want like if I can throw in
this very age-old adage by uh apparently
by Henry Ford you know if I asked my
customers what they want they would have
asked for Faster Horses right uh uh so I
think in we're in this uh industry where
the user is a wallet wallet is almost an
identity and that identity does not have
like something like an email or a
persona for example so I think when
building for this user what H how can we
as Builders effectively collect data or
what patterns we can observe to actually
solve problems like what are the actual
problems rather than shipping out
features left and right right and I
think I would start with Austin here
kind of like cuz you spend a lot of time
of your day building talking to users
and building for users so how how do you
go about it
then yeah just to start I think the Ford
Foundation can't confirm this quote uh
but I think they said something like
that's something like he would have said
uh so we can all make a tcid agreement
that that he said it um and I think in
this case the key is um to to try to
find the subtext you know when someone
tells you they're having a problem or
they want a product or a feature request
um in this case it would be like they
want to go faster right um people are
experts in their problems and and the
challenges they face but not necessarily
and how to solve them um and so uh yeah
I I think that it's uncovering uh the
fundamental human need um and there
aren't actually that many um you know as
I mentioned ear I think sometimes people
want stability um they want their time
back they want money they want rewards
of the tribe so you know social
affirmation from the people around them
um they might enjoy the reward of the
hunt you know um like for example I know
like the analyst on duner I think enjoy
the hunt I think they want to find that
insight and there's also an element of
uh self-mastery you know like let's see
what I can create um but it's really
there I don't think there are that many
fundamental human needs so I think it's
uh trying to be clear um you know not
talk about the features uh necessarily
that we're that we're shipping all the
time and we
as designers like I could get better at
this and I most like everyone could get
better at this just like tying this to
like a really core fundamental need I
think we don't because it sounds too
simple um but uh but I think sometimes
there's a sophistication in simple um
yeah there's a bunch of different things
you could do
so one thing with the data is always to
marry quantitative with qualitative so I
do a lot of the Quant stuff I've done
qual stuff in the past but we we've got
some lovely people at safe who do it
very well uh but it's understanding how
people are using your tool from the data
but then going and asking them and
there's a lot of techniques you can use
you know why you ask five times why so
you say you need this why do you need it
and then you ask that five times and
you'll realize that the fifth answer is
so completely different to what they
said initially because people tend to
think I want this and they tend to think
about the future that they want rather
than the problem they're trying to Sol
with that feature and you as the
engineer as the dev you're better place
to understand kind of how to
technically answer that needs um that
someone without the context of how your
product is built can um but I face the
same thing with data you know I'm
surrounded by people who say I want this
metric and if you ask them why do you
want this metric it's to measure an
outcome and I realize that the metric
they actually want doesn't quite match
the outcome it's about well if you want
to measure that outcome I suggest we
track this or that metric and it's
always coming back to as an expert it's
about being able to realize you're the
expert in the room and um trying to
understand from your users what they
really need and I have to say like in
web 3 we're still such a small space
that we can go out to users users want
our products to grow they're they've
adopted our products and they want to
keep them you know evolving and we
should leverage that relationship that
we have that in web two it's really hard
to do you know here here people want to
help you out you know and they want to
see have a better experience using your
product going forward so let's leverage
that as
well yeah please yeah to that point I
mean we I I I completely agree I think a
lot of times in in the research space
there's this battle between uh the
qualitative feedback people and the
quantitative feedback people um either
they're wired that way or that's where
their skill set is um but I think that
they tell different parts of the story
um so you know you have I think the
quantitative is really good at telling
you what's happening um and you know
observing actual Behavior because a lot
of times people don't tell you um or
they're not even aware of their their
actual Behavior but then you can follow
that up with you know conversations or
observing the space and this doesn't
always have to be like formal long form
interviews um I think we do a pretty
good job right now just uh by you know
Enga I'm trying to do this more uh
engage on Twitter or in telegram groups
and get it's it's not just one
conversation it's kind of a relationship
and you can get that kind of like
ambient signal and then see is there any
discrepancy between that and like the
actual Behavior or the data and maybe
there's like something interesting there
like something that's worth worth
exploring um so
yeah yeah I think what you described um
how you approach like um pulling data
and getting like an overview of
different um crypto interactions is what
we can already track about them on chain
but there are also some parts of the
user um flow or flow of funds that we
might not see yet so from when we look
at the capital markets industry it's
very um common that for very big trades
when we think about ETFs or large funds
when a rebalancing happens or someone
basically dissolves a position those
trades are not made like in the public
market um but because they have the
potential to move the market so they are
then fractionalized and traded away in
for example dark pools where there's
like an OTC so an offchain matching
about like um where the the buy and the
sell side agree on a price and then it
gets basically cleared and traded and
settled and so on so um those type of in
more institutional use cases and they
are still done in the centralized
exchange context um because here we have
well logic like we know them from stock
markets and bond markets and so on so
there are some data points that yeah we
don't see yet so it's really important
to yeah know the user and the ultimate
goal where he wants to but sometimes our
technology also has advantages where the
user doesn't know what feature he wants
because he doesn't really know that this
is a problem that's already solvable and
you have to Pioneer the technology so
this is where we we still have some
frictions and it makes sense to pay
attention also have like user interviews
often and not only do the data analytics
so I have a question on the you
mentioned like uh a use case of uh
rebalancing portfolios right so if I
remember correctly this is like there
are programmable uh Solutions out there
that'll automate rebalancing of
portfolios right so essentially these
are I guess you can call them Bots you
know and when you look at like from a
data angle when you look at activity
onchain uh transactional
activity are we seeing essentially Bots
as real users are we an industry where
Bots are legitimate users it depends my
my answer is always it depends it
depends on what you're trying to measure
right so I read a stat the other day I
think Chad GPT gave me that stat but 50%
of internet activity is bots so I think
it's no lower in crypto it's probably
higher
um if they're airdrop farmers and you're
trying to measure real adoption of your
chain and they're just farming for your
Chain's airdrop then you probably don't
want to see them as real users but if
they're active traders who are actively
using your D5 protocol and are making
60% of the
volume I'd say they probably are active
users they're generating the volume that
you're getting fees from or that you're
you know they are generating real
activity they are powered by by humans
at the end of the day who are using your
protocol actively in comparison to
another D5 protocol to to make money
could could you want to add yeah maybe
connecting to what you said with the
Bots and that they are probably also a
higher amount in our industry and when
we think about air trop farming also
hamster like maybe some of you saw the
presentation earlier ton I mean like the
technical approach to it is really
powerful I think and abstracting gas
fees or have payment Master accounts
like has a great potential for um more
the average users but in the trading
space for example um here we have also
like some very granular um differences
when we for example look at the amount
of accounts right um ton showed us these
accounts numbers but or wallet numbers
that have been spin up um in telegram
but actually like I use this um to to
air to farm or hamster the air drop or I
gave it to my daughter when she had like
too much energy um but then after 3 days
we forgot about it and since then it's
like a dead account um so I think that's
still like part of that um but there are
also some bot or trading activity that
has like very different logic um and
where it's powerful for example like in
from the trading side um and I think the
financial side is still like one of the
most um relevant when we think about the
blockchain like the impact that
blockchain can have for the users uh
that don't have access yet so here I can
also talk more and more but I want don't
want to take up more space the the
question is really how what what's the
quality of that user whether it's a
human or bot it doesn't really matter
what's what's the quality and what's the
kind of long-term quality of of that
user you you mentioned I mean it's it's
interesting actually it's kind of going
to the topic what I wanted to also
highlight which is uh definition of a
active user in web 3 where you know
identity is so fragmented in our space
uh we use accounts like uh almost like
avatars uh right so so what is what is
uh the the current definition of a an
active user uh and I'm kind of curious
how from a quantitative side how you
look at it and from a qualitative side
how Austin would probably look at it at
as a user perhaps you know how Romina
would have that perspective of uh
categorization you're opening a can of
warms um I don't know who was at dunon
yesterday but I think every other talk
was talking about how it's very
difficult to measure active users how
this measure it flored
Etc I think again it depends on your
project so we're not just measuring
things we're trying to understand
measure outcomes measure the success of
a particular product of a particular
feature so an active user can mean very
different things for different protocols
you know so safe started off for example
as a self- custody multi- solution it's
the safest smart contract out there to
save your to keep your
funds the way we could have measured
active users four or five years ago was
how many users are depositing funds
storing value in saves you know now
we're trying to get with the world
evolving and smart accounts becoming uh
more prominent we're trying to bring
activity led by smart accounts and not
just EA so what's important to us is how
many users are actually using those
funds that they deposited on safes while
back so an active user that could have
been just a user depositing funds now
becomes an user that is actually using
those funds and trans transacting volume
right so it really depends on your
product and you have to think about what
definition makes sense in in that
context now I also have like a bunch of
fer groups in mind or how I break them
down so I think when we start with the
crypto natives we would have the Wales
or we would have the Deens that ape we
would have the crypto cuers that um take
the time and get involved but it's not
like they're doing a lot or have like a
lot of funds that they are gambling
around with and then we have like the
for example the emerg market user that
does uh that uses um it for remittance
or also for um a wealth creating product
um so here just like stable coin
adoption or whatever so yes these are
probably also single wallets or here we
we can trace like wallet interactions
but when we um think about like Capital
markets then a wallet is not a user so I
would be careful to always for to
generalize that a wall wallet is always
equivalent to a user because we have sub
account Logics right where like accounts
execute certain strategies or it's a
vault or whatever and the user is not
the wallet but it's like on a very
different aggregation level um and yeah
I think like when we think about in the
numbers of for example the speed of
transaction right like which infrastru
structure or um route are they taking
through like the trades it's very
different for example high frequency
trading would would also need to use
very different combinations of chain or
would have also um cross chain or
multi-chain
complexities um they are much easier um
for like let's say investors value
investors that hold positions and have
sometimes um like a trade and here it's
yeah more about abstracting probably
like the general Key Management the
chain management and yeah so I see like
very different angles a lot of what you
actually shared as a user uh these tend
to be like offchain uh interactions or
workflows this is actually some can be
onchain as well but like I guess a lot
of I just on train examples I try to
give yeah but did like uh or not
financial institutions I didn't um
explicitly describe that because they
also have wallets and need certain user
functionalities and here we have a big
impact for safe uh for
example uh there's a lot of offchain
activity of like collecting approving
signatures uh which which which uh means
that the users are actually interacting
with your app uh and there it's just one
simple use case right and when we spoke
about quantitative data qualitative data
a lot of the uh industry reports tend to
focus or overly focus on like onchain
activity as like there are workflows
yeah in organizations where like um
wallets are already used so I think like
there so safe is one approach right just
like a multi sick approach and there it
already has like the permission
management but then there's also other
wallets um or yeah basically signature
tools like fire blocks right we have
like MPC and privacy technology here
also security um technology that helps
to um abstract uh key management but
also allows for like building an
interface and then you have like
different permissions for depending on
which user or what they can see you know
that they don't see all the data or not
or you can have randomizers over certain
wallets so that like if an exchange in
the category of a financial institution
for example that um people that send
funds to a wallet that is owned by a
centralized Exchange they wouldn't be
able to trace like all the other wallets
of a centralized exchange right
so yeah and I think uh I want to like
get some of uh Austin's uh perspective
so I just want to shift Focus uh a
little bit um just compared to web 2
right like we're talking about offchain
onchain like what are some like
tradeoffs that you feel like we make in
web 3 that differ uh from web 2 in terms
of like General practices
oh man I had a really good answer to the
last question you'll have to come to my
next panel um but uh uh so some
tradeoffs um I think as I mentioned
earlier we've been um we've been
optimizing for like solving very
fundamental problems around like
decentralization um and autonomy and you
know like I said I think those are table
Stakes now um and we have to start
thinking about maybe until
we until we really uh improve the kind
of web 3 experience to exceeds the web
two experience we have to think about um
how we can use those moments so for
example like uh you know how can we
alter our language to speak to people
more clearly how can we communicate you
know we talked about are you a privacy
purist or um or kind of you know a data
a wallet Wanderer or more of a utility
Seeker I think uh copy is actually
really important like to communicate the
message I think a lot of times we put
tons of information in the documentation
um or in the t's and C's and uh this is
something a lot of times teams don't
have copywriters and it's something that
I think a lot of designers reluctantly
do um but it's worth taking the time and
is a pain point you know for me uh to
really communicate clearly the The
Exchange like what are you getting and
what are you giving um especially if you
want to on board more people um I think
that's super important and then just
things like you know fix you know transa
like uh transactions taking a lot of
time um you know these sorts of things
like until we fix that we have to think
about those as opportunities to you know
educate or entertain or engage um so
there are lots of little moments like
that that are slightly different in web
3 but ideally we just we just solve that
yeah and and we we can we can move on to
you know creating Next Level experiences
and we're not trying to like fill these
moments with uh with
fixes um I think I just want to like as
we're nearing probably like we got like
8 minutes left and I wanted to kind of
shift Focus maybe like the future
outlook of our industry uh so the
question to all of you all uh preferably
is uh looking ahead like how can the the
web 3 Industry on board like a diverse
user base without compromising user
privacy are there emerging tools or
practices Frameworks that you feel like
you're excited
about uh yeah maybe I can um connect to
one of the examples I gave earlier that
was around signat signature management
so Solutions like fire blocks um NPC
technology or um CK kyc um like Mina
protocol or a few other projects are
working on um yeah basically verifying
that you're like for example allowed
you're on the allowed list to use a
certain um service without sharing your
private data that can be like yes from
exams from the financial world but it
could also be related to health data and
so on where it's really sensitive data
that should not get access um to other
people so with MPC you would for example
expose that data um but uh you would not
um um exposit data you would conceal
that data but for example
MPCs uh you would always have like um um
yeah part of the secret would always be
held by the um NPC technology provider
Ider um but fhe for example fully
homomorphic encryption uh yeah is
basically yeah where you can see or the
data and
also um yeah verify it in
a in a bit more complex technical way I
I'd probably challenge this a little bit
I I don't think the way to get towards
privacy is to give a third party exactly
access that's why you have to choose
different types of privacy Technologies
depending on the use case that's what I
was trying to to to highlight here um
and I think like there's there's this
part of what type of data is interacted
and what is the right approach to secure
privacy um and it could be for example
we don't want to interact with um
criminals or to have exposure to tated
funds or that for example our insurances
would know like um what we have gen IC
um yeah how you say like more likelihood
that we get like a certain um deathly um
uh disease but there's also more like
the surveillance St type of data that
many people have in mind so um yeah yeah
I think we operate in a little bit of a
tricky place because we started well
blockchain ethos kind of started as
privacy preserving um that quickly went
away when you know uh you had um all
these tools that are coming in where you
can follow the history of all the
different wallets and what they do on
chain and how they connect to each other
and you've seen you know um authorities
get using that data to to ban certain
activity or to ban certain wallets I'm
not saying that's a bad thing I'm just
saying the truth is everything's on
chain everything is available and tools
like Dune are making that data even more
digestible um so we have to think about
I think we're at Crossroads we have to
think about how we use data and how
because the truth is companies
organizations are always want going to
want to know more about their users
because they want to grow because they
want to maximize profits because
whatever reason it is they are going to
want to know more and they're going to
leverage this onchain data is it okay is
it okay that we're able to track a whole
transaction history and base our product
on this is it okay that we're able to
connect a wallet to an ID entity because
someone's doxed it or put that
information on chain online sorry um and
is it also you know what what kind of
product tracking are we putting in place
that's not on chain that's like
proprietary data and we need to think
about how we do that as well um are we
always gdpr compliant you know are we
when we match the data we collect off
chain to some data that we might collect
on chain are we doing it in a way that
is um privacy preserving for our users
and most importantly are our users
totally aware of what you know they're
they're signing in the tnc's it's what
you were saying earlier um and and what
they're giving away for for the
usability of of the product I think that
would be relevant in permission setups
right but if you have permission less
setups maybe like um yeah being
compliant to a current already outdated
gdpr um directive is maybe maybe not
like what you should orientate um
yourself about so let's think about a
second example that would be um the uh
transfer rules for financial
institutions where basically for every
crypto transactions and we don't have
that in the Fiat system and financial
institution would have to store like the
or collect the data of the sender the
recipients their identification the
source of funds or whatsoever it's like
like a very poor requirement and
technologies that they um have been um
adopting where we already have like
really impactful Solutions in the crypto
space that could protect also users um
that haven't been anticipated yet or
Technologies in gdpr and um
yeah
awesome let's see so I think that web 2
has and the internet in general has
proven that people are not that
concerned about their privacy um For
Better or Worse that but I do think
counter to that uh we're given a lot of
data and a lot of information um
sometimes it feels like uh you know it
can be a blessing or a curse I think
sometimes we have a hard time finding
the signal in that data um which can be
a real challenge something we're working
on um but I think it's not so I don't
think we need to make decisions for
people I just think we need to
communicate clearly you know what is it
that you're giving what is it that
you're getting um for example you know
like uh I'm not transactional when it
comes to my friends or my family or my
community but if I'm engaging with you
know a government if I'm paying taxes or
if I'm you know getting a subscription
with a company like I want to know like
what am I giving and what am I getting
and I think we just we be as clear as
possible about that and the design and
the product and let people make decision
for themselves and obviously there will
be a parallel you know government uh
conversation I assume someone's handling
you know compliance uh that's you know
they usually tell
us so yeah so I I want to have uh one
last round of like a lightning round of
questions so if you had a magic wand and
you could ask for any feature as a user
in web 3 what would that
be okay connecting to to my most recent
painful experience I would like to have
like um an account that um abstract the
gas fees and allows me for multi-chain
interactions when I for example want to
do a multi-chain um bridging of funds
and trades or yeah um having pool assets
from different chains for example
something from the poka environment
where it is not uh where it's even more
painful than
ethereum watch it
uh so at the moment um we're working on
integrating AI more into kind of the
data analyst workflow at Dune and uh
unexpectedly I found that really
powerful personally um I'm relatively
new to the space you know trying to
learn SQL um but being able to kind of
have this conversation uh it's really
like an education you can see the diff
on the on the left and the right um and
so I think I think more of that um uh
right now we had this kind of past year
of um you know an explosion of AI but
like using it uh like intelligently like
where people already are I think is uh
could be a lot of fun could be really
useful um probably wish will thinking
but I like one place where I can
interact with all crypto web 3 stuff
like all my balances in one place being
able to use all my funds and and one one
place that I trust and I I can self
custody my funds in a secure
way I I agree as well I think as we
mature as a user and Industry I think we
converge to having Simplicity uh
essentially um with that we are a minute
over time that concludes our panel uh
thank you to Romina Austin and Alice uh
thanks for sharing all the information
really thanks
everyone Thanks for
we have q Anda I yeah that was
an that was an amazing panel thank you
everyone please don't forget to scan the
QR code so you can write your questions
uh in the in the app so we can follow up
with with some questions for uh the
panel here so please we have we are
going to have a minute to have that so
please because we ran out of microph
phone so we need to do it from here so
please please go
ahead we have plenty of time for
questions so please go ahead with a QR
code
see awkward silence uh no I think there
are no questions uh people have already
left and the the next ones are waiting
for do do we have one question is it
yeah there is a question oh maybe we can
pass microphone that's more user
friendly it has to be through
technology okay then maybe we have to go
to that personone
you can come ask your question on on
stage you want to yell out your
question thanks
for okay thank you so um I want to ask
about that u u you state that um
sometime we uh when we talk to user um
we should Define the thing that user
does not know what he really want for so
how to track the thing that uh the user
does not really know
about uh when you develop a product and
uh I have another question uh that is
that true that um the first step when
you uh develop your product is to uh uh
to ask your customer or we need to find
uh some uh prior step for maybe for
example to uh uh analyzing the market or
something something like that so that's
own of my uh two
question I I think the the first
question summary if correct me if I'm
wrong is more about like how do we know
what the user actually no uh says what
they want versus what they actually need
right how do we get to the the need Gres
there rather than what they are asking
for essentially if I'm correct if if
it's yeah yeah the the unhelpful answer
is it depends but I think if if you have
to pick like a particular Playbook um
you know start with a hypothesis or a
particular question that you want to
answer um dig into the quantitative data
if you have it and even if you haven't
started a project yet you know it's a
lot of data Unchained like you can
probably go out there and find some
signal um and then uh try to understand
what's happening and then follow up you
know with maybe build something and get
some feedback or if you feel like you
really need to discover you know you can
go you can follow up and go talk to
people and and try to follow answer that
question essentially but you you might
have
some um no that's a good good point I I
maybe just adding on this if you are
actually talking to a user if they are
making a feature request then that's
probably a signal that that's already
too narrow and too precise like try to
understand why do they need that feature
and then you might agree that that
feature is indeed what responds to their
needs or you might disagree and think
that another feature or a different the
feature built in a slightly different
way might respond to their need
better yeah yeah maybe to make it more
um yeah clear with a specific example so
um this multi-chain um feature um
multi-chain trading right like I had to
write for every step of my trade it was
just I actually just wanted to leave a
position it was Stables versus like a
certain token and for every little step
of onchain interaction I had to write a
support request but my actual goal goal
was to just like Swap usdc and a token
from a different chain and it had like
10 steps involved that I couldn't
navigate through because there was no
help text or on on that
website yeah I think it's just nailing
down on that is uh getting to the root
cause and not focusing on the symptom is
like why are they trying to do so
something and uh you know really drill
them to the point that they actually
disclose the problem they're trying to
solve not the feature that they're
trying to use
essentially uh I didn't quite catch your
second question but perhaps we can uh
catch uh after and maybe discuss that
all right there's one for you Austin we
have we have one question we have
someone with the microphone wait waiting
and after your question we'll go with
the questions here in the screen uh well
actually my uh it's not that I had a
question and I lost the momentum but I
had a comment about the pause uh between
you asking us for a question and silence
so I scan this code it asked me to uh
enter some wallet I clicked the button
it asked me to do something I'm like no
I'm not that interested in this one so
uh yeah and uh actually I have answer to
the question that was asked because I
I'm always triggered as a person
responsible for a product I'm always
triggered with the quote from Henry Ford
about if I asked people uh what they
need they will tell me they need a
faster horse uh the answer to this one
is simple you do not ask people what
they want you ask people what problems
they have what what they do on daily
basis and then it's your job to figure
out the way to for them uh to solve
their problems and then you present some
prototype to them if it sticks you did
your job well so yeah thank you okay
thank
you thank you thank you that
was so we have three questions here so
to what extent will AI impact the role
of designers in the
future oh Hot Topic um I mean I'm
personally excited about it I mean we're
we're on this ride uh so like you might
as well enjoy the ride
um and you know anecdotally i' I've um
I've seen it be really powerful like
there's a ton of things that we're doing
as designers which is really um tedious
and and you know Annoying um and and I
think in the short term um you know like
if it's integrated into workflows
intelligently um I haven't seen this in
design yet uh very effectively you know
figma launched a bunch of AI features
recently and it hasn't really been
sticky in my workflow like maybe I need
to be more aggressive about you know
changing my habits just like learning
shortcuts you kind of have to brute
force your way into like new habits when
it comes to something you do you know 10
hours a day um but yeah so far it's it's
a playground uh I see it as an
opportunity um I haven't aside from you
know the classic just chat chat GP a
conversation partner to to explore
topics and ideas um actually that's been
really powerful just to be like hey I
need an icon for this like give me 10
ideas you know like because a lot of
times you have to create choices before
you make choices as a designer but
unfortunately often it's just you
staring at your screen um and so to have
like that brainstorming partner at least
at the moment I mean that's been the
main way it's affected my workflow for
now um in a positive way and yeah I'd
say like it's happening we're long for
the ride I I'm I'm generally
optimistic about
it awesome we have time for one more
question from what is written here I'm
trying to choose the right one we have
one more
here okay sorry uh I was trying to put a
new line and it actually posted the
question uh uh my question is like when
you are trying to develop a B2B
application and other uh uh the party
the business is not working in a web 3
space uh how what is the best way to
onboard such uh business users so maybe
I can give an example where um the
solution would basically combine two
different chains um so for example
friend of mine has developed um AI
agents for uh web to users or you know
like from that World um and basically
the approach was to combine um a near
based approach so where it's basically
abstracting a bit more designed for web
2 users in mind and then basically there
was like a bridge in or basically
interactions with ethereum or evm
compatibility so um navigating ethereum
was actually not so relevant everything
that this B2B web 2 user was um
experiences was experiencing was pretty
much like the same ux as you would have
in the web 2 logic so there many
solutions to different
problems awesome thank you so much
please give a great Applause to this
panel
today
appreciated we will have a break and
we'll be here in 30 minutes at 3:30 to
begin the afternoon talks so thank you
everyone and we wait for you for the
next sessions
[Music]
t
br
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
to
oh
[Music]
to
is
[Music]
you oh
e
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
m
for
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
n
e
[Music]
m
a
[Music]
oh
SC oh
[Music]
hey hello everyone welcome to to this
afternoon session at stage two thank you
very much for coming on time coming next
we are going to have a conversation
about human coordination and what's
behind those so please give a big
Applause to S Lee with cultivating the
under story building resilient
DS and please don't forget to scbe the
QR code that you will see during the
session to ask questions and please go
ahead thank you thank you hi
everybody
hello wow so way more people than I
thought when I walked in there were like
five people thank you so much for coming
on time awesome so uh my talk is
actually about cultivating the under
story and how many of you guys actually
familiar with the concept of under story
here okay one
oh how many of you guys actually never
heard of a word under story
before wow is that a isn't not a new is
not a is not an English word can someone
tell
me not sure okay yeah so under story is
something that I DBL into like recently
last few years uh as I
really become a like a nature inspired
uh entrepreneur that's what I kind of
introduced myself uh and I'm like so
into is the plurality and The Duality
and in and yang and Harmony and balance
that's what I'm mostly focusing on this
day and when I think about like design
in community I always go back to Nature
and I try to get inspiration and then
now I found the concept of overstory and
under story and I want to take you guys
to a journey with me to the forest today
and it's not um about I'm going to share
something completely new to you it's
more like I'm going to zoom out and they
really share what you already know but
rediscovering with me does it sounds
good awesome cool yeah so in a healthy
Forest what's really happening is
actually um there's under story and the
over story and over story is uh what you
see above the ground which is like
plants trees canopies and big big big
things that is so visable that you
always get distracted by but to have a
healthy trees and healthy overstory you
would need an under story that is
healthy as healthy as that without under
story you would not have a healthy
overstory right so what's in the under
story which is basically a network of
roots and a fungus system and soil
organism that is um so important but
it's not visable enough and it make all
the life of all possible and and this
underst story is not just a supporting
role of the forest but it's actually the
foundation so without that soil system
there is no roots growing and then no K
can of canopy or no trees growing right
so our Dow is actually metering those
Forest system imagine our human
coordination and our community and our
team is also hi distracting me
um uh is a forest then we in th space
right now obsessed with our visable
structure like our token system our
onchain governance and uh the Frameworks
and toomics and the voting and
everything that is uh not really a
underst story when you look at it and
it's so much of like okay I'm the tree I
want Sun I want to be higher so that's
all the energy that we spending to grow
over story but not taking care of the
under underst story yeah so I am oh I
went
back so but if our Dow system and our
community our team is like just like a
forest
imagine if we keep feeding only the over
story and just admiring without putting
investing our energy and time into the
under story what's GNA happen and our
success is a purely depends on something
that are far less
visible that is in the underst story so
what is that so my name is Soni uh I am
from Korea living in different parts of
the world uh I built one of the first a
Bitcoin SMS wallet in the
2012 13 and after that I built the did
system and then uh last five years I've
been deling into this community design
governance design and build building
real resilient Community which is very
hard uh I've been doing a lot of
different experiment bringing web to uh
and web 3 and together and also bringing
ancient wisdom into the technology
spaces so I call myself like crypto
Anthropologist if that makes sense so
that's who I am I just wanted to unpack
today with you guys what is that underst
story and don't be surprised again it's
not something new you already know what
that is is actually oh sorry it's
actually you you guys are the underst
story I will tell you a little bit more
what is that mean when I say you is
actually your story it's actually your
experience it's actually your belief
system and it's a value system do you
carry it's it's hidden assumption do you
carry and it's a cultural background and
cultural wisdom that you actually carry
with you and that's the under story and
how many of you guys here actually felt
like I've heard
by my team member
fully okay one two great and how many of
you guys I feel like you know what they
actually know my
story my journey all right but not still
not a majority of it yeah and how many
of you guys
actually saw witness the team member
that are absolutely great Builder but
left the team because of the human issue
more and how many of you guys have feel
like I'm not really fully connected with
the mission of organization unless the
founders doesn't count if you're
employee you don't like um you know what
I kind of get it I'm doing this for
money but I'm not really connected and
convinced and is there's no
communication whatsoever they don't feel
like they don't treat me as a as a as a
person but more like a tool or have you
ever experienced there
before okay good yeah so I just wanted
to show you guys not just a feeling of
what's missing but what's really missing
in the industry and this is the number
uh a $359
billion is annually spent to solve the
human conflict in the traditional
organization and also 40% of almost
every manager's time which is a two-fold
day is spent on human coordination
and also
213% of a brilliant key contributor of a
salary a 200 233% of their salar is
actually spending to replace them so
there is a it's not just like a feeling
or sad or you know I'm not hurt I'm not
sin is actually the organization
spending so much time and energy and
resource to solve that understory issue
so if you're neglecting under story this
is the money that you spend okay you say
like oh you know what this is like
traditional organization number but in
Dow is actually worse right these
challenges are intensified during during
the Dow action and work because
traditional organization at least they
have some rule they have a clear
contract and they have to deliver some
certain thing and then they come to the
office every day they work together they
eat together they try something whatever
they can do but still it takes so much
resource
to solve all this human issue and
cultural issue in doubt our work across
a time zone and a culture and the value
system is all different and our
governance tools often just assuming the
rationality of it but not touching
emotional or context enough and also our
focus on the trustly system like we
focus so much about like building
trustly system and we sometimes forget
that what we are yawning for is actually
the trust so that's what's happening in
Dows
and how are we addressing this you know
I don't think I've never been in a dow
that is have like a trillions whatever
like so much of like resources and in
the treasury they're focusing on this as
their first priority and then what
happened is they actually lose a lot of
their treasury money they even shut down
because of human issues
I've been in the space for like more
than 12 years I've seen so many time
teams broken including my own team teams
break project break break and Community
disappear because of the human issue
it's not about technology it's not about
uh uh a government's framework right so
you guys kind of get it where I'm
heading right now yeah so to do do that
again we have to invest in the under
story of the forest we have to have like
really healthy soil to make sure that
our trees are growing well and
it's
um here we go yeah and what we're
missing when we design
community and
Dows we miss often the person you know
when when we talk about Dow
decentralized autonomous organization I
always put a first you know you we have
to be autonomous human being to be
connected with the decentralized network
then you become an organization or
organism whatever you want to call it
without a focusing on
individual autonomous being there is no
decentralized network that is connected
you know if you are not ready if you're
not willing to take uh conflict if
you're not willing to openly communicate
if you're are not willing to actually
invest in yourself to become a better
person so you can function in the very
complex uh society which is Da uh it's
really important that we actually pay
attention to myself and to each other so
your story your experience your
worldview these are like when you pay
attention um to those things and
sometimes you know when we share our
story people like oh it's not needed you
you guys probably experience even here
when you walk into the conference the
first thing people ask you is that what
do you do is not about who you are so
what do you do what's your job are you
relevant to me are you giving me
something are you are we transitional
relationship uh if it's not valuable for
me that people just walk away I mean
etherum consist them a little less but
if you go like somewhere else it's like
really like a jungle right it's like
everybody like okay what do you have
what do you have this is what I have
like show me my card and if it doesn't
connect we're done and we just wasting
our time and energy but if you really
sincerely care about that person in
including your team member and then your
Dow people to ask what's your story
what's your experience why are you
thinking that way that I cannot
understand sometimes and just unpack
those story it's not a distraction from
the work and actually they are the
foundation of your relationship and your
work and your doubt so that's I kind of
key message that I want to uh bring it
up so then now I know okay your story
and our individual story our individual
value system is underst story then how
can we cultivate that right and often
time we are human that people think that
we know what we're doing and how we
interact with other human but sometimes
it's really hard um and I have like a
specific four nature related elements
that I want to share with you guys um
and this is a basically again using the
unders story uh narrative and then there
is a fourth thing that I want to share
with you guys and this is the order
right like I mean not ordering to do
what you do but like this is in order so
uh thinking of about like following the
journey again the number one is actually
a context so when you start a
conversation with your team member if
you're a leader you want to create this
is really safe space for everybody and
then try to cultivate the under story of
your team you have to understand the
context is number one thing that you do
in our nature system is like a living
soil so everything begin with a context
and it's a soil component right and um
when there is a no soil there's a
nothing can grow and then soil mean
being here is like your living
experience cultural wisdom personal
motivation and then hidden assumption so
you have to unpa that through uh anyhow
with a conversation or there's a lot of
different technique that you can use to
unpack those things and number two when
the soil is there the first networks
form uh as a communication so once you
the the soil is very rich and star
fungus system you know like a melium
system start forming together it's like
a connecting the new neuron and also um
uh kind of like a initial pathway for
resource to connect and all these things
you I hope you guys are following me
with the visually uh and once that's
done the information is uh start to
flowing naturally and the trust in the
network is start to arise and then
invisible connection is formed the
people start to feel comfortable and
safe and then stories and ideas are
popping up only once you connected well
and have a good
context and uh number three is a
coordination so finally now we have a
soil now we have a A fungi system and
then What's happen is the root system
start to grow and that's our
coordination so with with the strong
very healthy rich soil and then uh a
strong communication Network that
coordination you don't need to do
anything people will start coordinate by
themselves we don't need to tell them to
do that so it will just form slowly and
like a root system grows you know
sometimes you find like roots in the on
the street they're like why why are you
here you cannot ask them because they
just do things what they supposed to do
and that's what's going to happen in our
Dow system so if you're a leadership
just remember have a very clear context
and then a context is building huge huge
huge rich soil and then you just do a
little bit of a sporing to build that a
phun GU system and then coordination
will happen automatically without having
so much effort
but last thing it will be uh interesting
take uh I'm I love to hear your thought
on this uh is a conflict I love conflict
and and conflict is extremely important
without conflict there is a no diversity
and when I say conflict is actually you
can take that as a resource once you
have a good soil good fungi system good
root system actually the conflict is
maximizing your growth you know you know
like sometimes we say trees when you
give them uh a stress they actually
produce a bigger uh fruit and the even
more sweeter fruits so imagine the
company is being that a great motivator
and the driver for the evolution uh and
I sometimes when I create a com not
conflict create a a community in D I
call it a community of per fermentation
so I just like a give a perment uh um
fermenting a period so conflict just
automatically arise without fermentation
what happened there's no gimchi there is
no sour though it takes time but it's
the order right so I just really
encourage like for uh Community to do
really explore themselves where the
conflict is and once you have a good
soil a conflict is nothing to be afraid
of but it's more to encourage and then
really using that to grow better
so that's kind of my uh four different
uh simple nature analogy and these are
so simple that you can actually review
and then revise um uh today at night
when you go to bed like huh says the
four C's right context communication and
coordinate and conflict just remember
those four thing and I hope you using
this for your understory cultivation
they'll be amazing and my Last Words um
it's a thank you slide but I love being
in the forest I really believe we are
missing out a lot not tapping into our
nature analogy and the nature wisdom so
once you go out to the forest and when
you walk into the forest you don't have
to think much you just walk around and
after that what do you feel you feel
healed you feel like oh you know what
actually now I feel way better but it's
completely effortless so one question
that I have if we we imagine creating
our organization and community and Dows
truly designed and operated by the
Nature's wisdom and the pattern of
nature what's going to happen I'm
already experiencing with the some of
the community that we recently started
with a complete nature analogy and then
nature wisdom and people are saying you
know what this is actually really
helpful and I feel like a better person
so how cool would that be if we create
something uh that is so much like a
forest that is a functioning Forest so
people walk into our community walk into
our Dow when they leave when they are in
the forest they say you know what being
in this community actually saved my life
or being in this community changed my
life and being in this community really
healed
me I think it's possible and then Dow is
no longer just the technology and voting
system governance framework we can go
beyond and we should be go beyond
and I'm really really looking forward to
build those um amazing nature uh
inspired Dows with you all thank you so
much should I be here that's awesome
that's awesome so thank you so much for
sharing all that knowledge with us and
all the experience so we are going to
start the Q&A round we have two
questions uh here on the on the screen
and then we'll we'll go with with you so
can a person be so bad for your soil
that it's better to ask them to leave if
they can't be helped to
change great question whose question is
this thank you yeah do you know soil
also rot you know not all the soil is
actually good soil if the soil is like
getting bad you have to take it out and
they live it somewhere and then you burn
it or you do whatever you need to do and
I oh the question is is can we go back
to the question sorry yeah
yeah and then um there is a something
that you can do uh you know when the
soil is actually not healthy then you
can give them a different nutritions to
make it better by using different
compost materials or whatever organism
that that that the soil is required to
do uh you can test the soil and you can
actually find out what kind of nutrition
the soil needs and you can provide that
but the when soil is bad it's really rot
then you have to take it out otherwise
it will spread right so that's kind of
my answer happy to chat more and uh nice
and we have another one are imperson
connections necessary or just helpful
for these cultural Connections in a DA I
love this question thank you so much for
reading my mind yes yes yes 100% you
need in person connection cuz what in
person connection does it's not about
just like oh you know what it's nice to
have meal with you and it's just like
haha ho ho sharing story you're actually
sharing a space with them and you get to
understand way better because you're not
only using a two senses which is a
writing and then seeing but you're using
all of your sense to understand the
other person so it's a way better
quality of conversation or communication
that you will have so you need to have
like if you're doubt I strongly
recommend at least every six month GA
together but not just for like football
game or ping pong game or for drinking
you know you have to have like a very
clear agenda how you want to share that
time because it's not easy to fly around
and then meet together and spending long
enough time to actually build this
underst story uh so this is another
thing that I'm actually doing uh as a
profession which is the experience
designing for the teams and theend Dows
so if you're really curious about how to
build the underst story and then
meaningful inperson Gatherings I'm here
to help so talk to me but I strongly
recommend and I wish we have more time
so I can share more about the key uh
secret recipe uh I know there is some
people who actually already participate
in the inperson Gatherings that I was in
can you raise your hands if you were
part of uh anything that I designed
before thank you so these people you can
go ask them and how different it
was awesome now we have a question here
from the
audience hi SII hi this is mitali I
wanted to ask you
um and sorry if this is a little
personal um when you reflect and go to
your past has there been any moment of
either conflict or a friction in a
relationship whether personal or
professional which you feel now after
embodying like um learnings from nature
and learnings from the forest that you
would deal with differently and if so
then how yeah there very good questions
um I didn't see conflict as a resource
from the beginning on yeah I was really
afraid of dealing with a conflict as a
Asian that's what we do we just like
swallow it and then like pass pass pass
uh but at some point I couldn't avoid
anymore so what happened was that I was
avoiding I was angry I was like try to
do not to face it but like Angry is also
part of like I think avoiding in some
way because angry means that you express
your feeling but you are not actually
communicating you're just like shouting
at one to the to the other person so
when that happened and eventually
actually that conflict the energy took
me over and it put me down uh and uh
that was a time that I kind of gave up
and then I found another way then I
start meditating I doing something so
that was I would say it's a failed a
conflict resolution but everybody
probably have to go um not that deep but
like in certain way that I'm you know
I'm done with this and I'm just and you
walk away you feel like oh you know what
me walking away from this it make me
feel so good and giving me peace and
that's actually good walk away but if
you feel like I truly TR actually don't
want this and I actually avoid it and
you have like something in your heart
and I have like a relationship that I
still haven't resolve and it's such a
little thing and it's been like 10 years
right it's like the back of your mind
all the time when you think of conflict
um and when I think about like a nature
analogy I think the compost thing is
really important so when we attach to
the one particular relationship that
everything has to be good all the time
it means we are not honoring the
seasonality of it so we want this to be
always spring and always summer but not
uh understanding there is winter coming
so I think using that seasonal analogy
to understand the conflict and also so
many other things it could be helpful so
when when when the winter comes you know
the trees lose their leaves and then
they all become rotten and what happen
in the spring is what is actually needed
from the nutrition that was there
whatever needs to come out come out out
in the spring and the composting is need
to be done well uh so I would say uh
conflict face
it honor it accept it even if you're
heart and there is a particular way that
you can actually manage conflict in the
group and the doubts and uh I'm happy to
share our conflict resolution um kind of
agreement every doubt that I created and
Community I created we always making
conflict conflict agreement or conflict
resolution agreement
because it's sometimes too late when the
conflict arise and there is no rule or
no code of conduct it's really hard to
imp place later so it's always good to
have a conflict resolution as a
prevention so you can actually um uh uh
when the bad act come after the
confliction based on this you can
actually make decision so those are the
things also kind of nature analogy yeah
without fixing it but like be prepared
yeah I hope that answers your question
thank you that was beautiful thank you
Soni please put your hands together for
S thank you so much
K thank you thank you everyone and don't
forget to place your questions using the
QR code each session each session has uh
in a minute we'll come with the next
talk thank you so much
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
all right coming next talking about
coordination there's legal challenges
that are very important to face to keep
on going so coming next is Dow and Bs
blending the best Ross minimization
techniques of the onchain and offchain
Worlds by Gabriel chapito please give
him a great warm
[Music]
welcome what's up
guys this way to do this probably like
that okay cool so uh this is going to be
very informationally dense um the talk
was labeled as intermediate but I am
going to kind of like speedrun through
the basics like super speedrun through
them so don't get mad that I'm going
fast um basically yeah it's it's to get
to the good stuff faster right and then
I'll slow down and take my time on the
on the detailed interesting stuff um
yeah I will as I go through I will be
saying some very opinionated and
potentially controversial things as if
they are fairly simple uh obvious trisms
the reason why I'm doing that is just
because it makes for a better talk uh
not because I'm like a fascist who who
doesn't understand all the Nu nuances so
you can always feel free to like
challenge me later on these various
assertions but it just kind of
simplifies simplifies the discussion
simplifies the presentation Etc so with
all that being said uh I'm Gabriel
Shapiro uh I am what they call a crypto
lawyer uh I'm also more recently a
founder of a company called metalex that
researches and develops uh certain uh
what we call cybernetic law solutions
that include uh governance issues for
dows
um covered that so first question is
like what is a DA I'm sure you guys have
heard this question ad nauseum today um
I will just say that like basically no
one agrees so the da that can be defined
is not the true da uh thus spake uh
Dau um there are kind of like two basic
answers you can give to this question
right oh and let me start my timer here
so I don't uh take too long um one is
like basically if you just looked at
everything that is called a
and Tred to honor that nominal Essence
so to speak that everyone uh gives it's
it's just way too many things right um
it's like Venture Capital funds that use
Smart contracts it's uh art collectives
um it's uh protocol protocol Dows things
that are governing you know defi defi
protocol parameters um just like some
people even call like Bitcoin itself a
dow as a network just many many many
things and about the best you could say
is that like it's some type of group of
people who use um blockchain for at
least some of their governance um or
like storing their assets or something
right um that's not a very satisfactory
or precise thing uh just to give like an
example there yeah like like metac
cartel Ventures da which which I
actually helped found and I'll be
mentioning throughout you know it's
really a venture capital fund it's an
LLC uh but it uses um like tokenized
voting right and and uses smart
contracts to hold the assets but you
know at the end of the day it's just a
Venture Capital fund right um so so
that's an example of like how diverse
these these things called Dows can be
right my answer is like I have a much
more opinionated answer uh which is I go
for like a purist definition of dows
right and I I just look at the word
right the acronym Dao right so at a
minimum Dows must be decentralized and
autonomous and some kind of organization
right what does decentralized mean it
means that whatever like the human
discretion is in running this thing um
like it's it's dispersed over large
agile and potentially anonymous group of
incentive aligned persons and we prefer
that it's like a permissionless or
relatively uh lightly permissioned um
like entry into that group so that it
can be very Broad and so that there are
no like unfair hoardings of power so to
speak and autonomous to me means that
it's self-governing self-governing trust
minimized and resistant to extrinsic
exercise of power so the intrinsic power
is decentralized and the extrinsic power
is hopefully close to elimin
um and and you can actually go back to
the original thing that inspired Dows
which is an article by Stan larer not
Dan larer although I think they might be
cousins uh arguing that Bitcoin is an
decentralized autonomous Corporation and
he had three rules uh for for what he
called Dax what we now called Dows um
that they basically have three laws of
robotics or what I we call Three Laws of
dowb botics law number one is that a dow
must run under the control of an
Incorruptible set of rules that are
implemented as publicly auditable open
source software law number two a dow
must not be able to change its rules
without the consent of its stakeholders
and such consent must not violate law
number one and law number three a dow
must seek to protect its own existence
as long as that does not violate law
number one or law number
two um now what is a borg you may have
heard this term U maybe not all of you
have heard of it but it is a cybernetic
organization hence Borg and what that
means is it's some kind of uh like real
legal entity could be incorporated or
unincorporated could be a partnership
but most likely is going to be
incorporated um where the rules of that
entity the legal rules of that entity
mandate the use of certain smart
contract or blockchain systems right so
this represents a blend of legal and
onchain Technology right um there are
two main varieties one is Dow adjacent
right so if you've ever heard of any
type of um multisig that can freeze a de
defi protocol or some type of Grants uh
multi-sig that is funded by a dow that's
basically a dow adjacent uh Borg um an
example would be like curves emergency
multisig it can freeze pools that are uh
younger than that are 30 days or younger
and it can stop curve rewards to a pool
and it can't really do anything else um
and the other would be like
bisboron ises all of its shares and and
lets them vote on chain and distributes
funds on chain
why is a borg not a Dao well it lacks
autonomy and it lacks decentralization
um basically it violates those rules I
mentioned earlier right um I won't dwell
on that but it's there in the slides if
you want to see exactly
why uh also side note why borgs and not
subd Dows you may have heard of the subd
Dow model well subd Dows are usually not
Dows they are usually small groups of
multisig holders again that for some
reason people call subd Dows so again
they violate those rules they're not
decentralized they're not autonomous
from a legal perspective you really
don't want um if these things are like
some small group of people who may incur
liabilities or do bad things you don't
really want them to be subd Dows because
then the Dow may have legal liability
for them you want them to be more
separate and
autonomous Securities laws also um you
know if like the Dow token holders are
basically like electing like just fully
electing these people and and it's more
of an agency type relationship you might
be turning your Dow to into into shares
into
Securities um so these things these like
we have various trust problems with Dows
and with multisig um and the ethos of
crypto is verified don't trust right so
the point of this talk the point of this
entire track is coordination right how
to solve these problems and borgs are
basically a technique for doing
this um the First Trust problem that is
faced uh by these like these like multi-
sigs in relation to Dows is member
management right often times uh when
when a multisig is a dow adjacent
multisig is proposed it's with like a
very specific membership set it might be
people who are doxed it might be people
who are pseudonyms like like the um
well-known bantag who's like very high
reputation as a Nim right but
nonetheless it is a specific set but how
do you accommodate over time membership
changes who decides that and the default
is that these things are just a standard
safe and therefore those people decide
the membership changes but but the Dow
seems to care who the members are um yet
the the people who were appointed they
can change their membership willy-nilly
and they never have to go back to the
Dow that's a problem right particularly
a problem if there is no other recourse
against these people as is typically the
case other than quote unquote reputation
slashing right if they do something bad
they will lose their reputation and they
will never be appointed to one of these
things again okay but that's great for
the initial set of potentially High
reputation people who are appointed but
what if it changes over time to like
lower reputation people or what if the
people who like claim to be on it like
immediately actually just like assign
the keys to someone else or something
and and you could never know right um
the other trust problem is asset
management right often these things I
mean I think like arbitrum recently
approved like a hundred over 100 million
to some like like gaming gaming grants
sporg type of thing right and they
they're putting in place trust
mitigation measures but this thing
happens all the time right these these
multisig uh get these Dow adjacent
entities get large amounts of money from
a dow right
um and this presents various issues um
number one uh like transparency of asset
management right um and like one thing
to notice is that if you just like you
may think that the fact that these funds
initially go to a multisig means oh it
will be transparent but actually in the
default case uh the multisig can just
immediately send them to a centralized
exchange or to a custodian uh or sell
them for Fiat and put it into a bank
account and all that transparency would
be lost and there's typically no nothing
that can be done about that there's no
legal rule against it um there's also no
onchain mechanism uh that typically
prevents it um so so the transparency
isn't really there actually um and uh
Asset Management accountability they're
supposed to do specific things with
these assets uh but there's often no way
to enforce that either again other than
this this sort of idea of reputation
slashing um the other issue is
permissions management right so I
mentioned curve emergency Dow uh curve
emergency Borg earlier that has certain
um
specific permissions over the curve
smart contract system but but it's only
supposed to use them for specific
reasons right um like basically if
there's some sort of Security emergency
so it would be like very bad if um
someone is on that multisig and uh let's
just say um well let's just say it's
someone from curve and let's just say
like Unis swap Community tried to do
like a uni stablecoin pool on curve um
and just because they're compe competing
protocols the curve people didn't like
it and they they shut off curve rewards
to that pool or they killed that pool
right um that would be bad because it's
not for a security reason right but
actually there's like uh no way to
really um like enforce that or even make
clear that that is an actual
rule um an example here from real life
is that kujira um basically the the devs
had a highly levered position themselves
in their own uh borrowing protocol and
they use their multisig authorities to
like change the parameters in their
favor and just like Kick the Can down
the road over and over again and
eventually resulted in a protocol
insolvency um that could have lost
people a lot of money if they were not
bailed out by uh Thor chain
people um the other thing is that like
you can actually have bad mitigations to
all the problems I mentioned right one
is that you um like basically you just
put the Dow in complete control of
everything and again that lapses into
the subd Dow model and then also May
really result in like an adverse
selection effect in terms of who the who
can contribute to the community so to
speak speak right because um if like you
can get rugged at any time by a dow well
really valuable serious people are not
going to operate under that they want
either employment law protections or
they want some kind of deal where like
if I produce X you will pay me Y and if
you don't pay me y I can come and sue
you right and that is not really
possible with that type of just make the
Dow Supreme type of mitigation so it
will lead to adverse selection and in
fact I know of quality teams that just
have a a rule of um you know we will not
we will not work with Dows we will not
do projects for
Dows uh a concrete example here is Juno
uh had set up a very complicated and I
thought somewhat promising looking subow
structure uh earlier this year and I I
think it took like months I don't know
all the details and and the Dow just
kind of changed its mind and rugged all
those people before it even really got
wrong now maybe they were doing some
stuff wrong I don't know but you know it
it shows how things could be bad right
and how people could be reluctant to do
these um there also are trust issues
faced by like extrinsic counterparties
right um like many law firms will not
will not represent Dows cannot represent
Dows right because they're not legal
entities um basically some of the things
that I mentioned like during the last
slide like third parties can get screwed
and and will often not not want to do
deals with
those um so to address these with borgs
there are basically two sets of
techniques one is onchain techniques and
one is offchain techniques and we try to
blend the best of both right I often say
like a lot of onchain stuff currently
that's like decentralized in name only
is actually the worst of Both Worlds
right it has none of the protections of
Law and it actually has like none of the
protections of true decentralization
either and so we actually tried to do
the opposite we try to do the Best of
Both Worlds with
borks um some of the onchain techniques
is like okay so almost all multisig are
what's called a safe it's a very
standard very battle tested very trusted
set of smart contracts originally by the
nosis team now it's an independent team
and the genius thing that they did is
they built hooks into these uh hooks for
guards and hooks for modules so without
ever altering the core code you can come
in and you can modify the way that a
safe functions and we actually use this
right we use this to limit the
discretion uh of the safe um and also to
enable third parties to do things to the
safe um and this results in a can't be
evil philosophy instead of a don't be
evil philosophy
so um guards basically constrain safes
right um like they basically can check
can you know they could literally limit
it to like only sending money to a
certain account or something like that
um and then modules expand saves like
they could allow a dow to uh come in and
send money out of the safe somewhere um
without the multisig signer signing that
transaction right um so we call both
these things implants keeping with the
cybernetic law type of theme right it's
like cyborgs um so like basically we can
like at a very high level the guards can
make the Borg a wh list style a Black
List style or a um or a Freestyle right
whitel list means everything is
prohibited by default except what we
specifically allow right so this could
be like let's just say it's a borg that
is only supposed to move liquidity among
specific Unis swap pools you could just
whitel list those pools and nothing and
they can't do anything else they could
just Shuffle liquidity between these
certain pools right um so it tends to be
good for thing borgs that have a lot of
money in them um you could also do we'll
talk about grants borgs but you can like
rate limit the the the the the speed at
which money comes out or like add
transaction size thresholds or things
like this right um Blacklist is like
everything is permitted except certain
things right so an example of this would
be like a borg let's just say it's a
token that retains a minable function so
it doesn't have a Cap supply and there's
a trust issue there right because the
people don't want to get infinitely
diluted for no reason so you could
Blacklist this Borg you could give it
the the permission to do to sort of um
basically it could like partially own
the mint mint function right so the in
order to exercise the mint function you
would need the approval both of this
safe or this Borg and the Dow for
example right and that would be an
example of a Black List um and then free
is like basically the safe can do
anything but maybe you want some of the
other functions that we're going to talk
about like member management functions
um so how do we address like the asset
management trust issues I mentioned
right so um basically let's just take
like a grant sporg as an example um we
can add like rate limitations right so
let's just say the idea that the Dow
approved is like this should be a fire
starter Borg um like it should give out
lots and lots of 50k to 100K grants and
no bigger right um and it should do this
like like several times a quarter for
three years or something like that well
we can actually program that in to the
to the safe right um and then they they
have to do that they can't do anything
different right um and you still want to
retain flexibility so the nice thing is
you can either allow like the the caps
and the rate limits to be crossed uh if
the Dow co- approves that along with the
safe uh or you can um put like uh a
potential violation of a cap or rate
limit subject to a time lock and allow a
dow veto uh within that time period
right depends whether you want to be
optimistic or pessimistic right so you
know we can Implement that veto
functionality and that co- approval
functionality you can also throw in like
anti-ds measures right if you're worried
about that you could have like like like
you're worried about the Borg will just
like spam the Dow and like overwhelm
it's like monitoring capabilities you
can impose cooldowns between proposals
right um member management issues so
this is the beauty of having a legal
entity right uh which we'll talk about
in a minute but like you can have one
legal entity that owns this multi
forever and its assets and it doesn't
matter how much turnover there is in the
members right it still has the same
rules and the same set of smart
contracts and all these things right so
but what we want to do is we may just
not want to allow like infinite
discretion to the safe members to change
their own membership so you could for
example require like a dow co- approval
or subject it to a dow veto when a new
member is added um you could potentially
say hey these guys might all collude and
there's no way to get them off so maybe
you allow the Dow to like unilaterally
remove that members even though it can't
unilaterally appoint members there's all
kinds of things you can do right but the
point is to drisk and and and Trust
minimize this member management function
right this could be very important for
an entity that owns IP for example right
um if like let's just say the entity's
rules say this particular safe everyone
who's on it is a director of this entity
and then the entity owns the IP well now
the Dow basically has like permanent
check and Balance style influence over
the IP and there's like no no risk of
disruption right right um things like
that uh you can also put in like
failsafe measures so that if like too
many like you can allow people to resign
um that helps basically with like trust
minimize it for the contributors right
because like typically someone can
resign from a company but you can't
actually do that in a default safe you
have to be voted off um you can also do
like asset reversion measures like if
too many people resign or whatever all
the money goes back to the Dow whatever
you want to do um and then there are off
train techniques for managing these
issues right so the first thing is like
have a legal rapper for your Dow at
Jason Borg uh we could sit here and
debate whether to have a da a legal
wrapper for your Dow itself I think this
is very very debatable and there are
significant cons to it but there are
almost no cons to wrapping uh your
multisig your Dow adjacent multisig in
illegal entity it as far as I can tell
it's like pure upside um uh uh other
than maybe some added expense right so
you know gets limited liability for the
workers it gets continuity for the Dow
that we discussed and then like entities
are much much like legal entities and
corporate entities are much much better
counterparties for third parties um than
like a general partnership with unclear
rules is right um so there's all kinds
of benefits um basically you say in the
legal docs of the entity that the entity
owns this particular safe and all the
Assets in the safe um and you also can
say something like everyone who's on
this uh uh in this safe is Aigner in the
safe is uh automatically a director of
this entity um and and vice versa anyone
who's a director needs to be on the safe
things like that right um you need to
choose the type of legal rapper wisely
uh I'll kind of skip through this
quickly because we're running out of
time but like corporations are not very
good legal rappers for Dow adjacent
multics they have very rigid rules llc's
are more flexible but they still have
the problem that like they're Geared for
like to be owned by people right and we
we actually don't want these entities to
be owned we want them to basically be as
close as possible to like the idea of a
legal smart contract right there's a set
of rules and there's people who have to
follow them but there 's no owner
there's no specific beneficiary Etc the
best for that as far as I've ever been
able to tell with all my research is
Cayman Foundation it's the only one that
kind of checks all the boxes some other
foundations can work but they have like
more rigid like founder structures or
beneficiary structures or reporting
things it just just came in as the best
right um and so here's how we actually
do this in like the legal documents
right so one you really want to Define
like the purposes of what this entity is
supposed to do right if it's a security
multisig its purpose is to defend
against security threats right you want
to say that in the documents therefore
it cannot use the assets for anything
else it cannot use the permissions for
anything else right um so we literally
spell that out we Define security
threats in this case it means any actual
or reasonably expected threatened imit
imp pending or ongoing frauds threats
misappropriations extortions abuses
hacks attacks etc etc against these
specific systems and those systems will
also be defined with like specific
contract addresses and things like that
um like of course you could always
debate these things and then of course
like you may end up in court but it's
still better than having like no
standard or no Road all um you can also
we already discussed like making your
safe members the same as your board of
directors um you can basically you can
be much more parsimonious in your legal
drafting than you could ordinarily
because instead of like spelling out
pages and pages of rules you could just
say whatever the rules are embedded in
that smart contract we have we have
agreed to them we've these smart
contracts and they embed our rules and
we just accept their outcomes right
um another one is uh this is very handy
with the with the foundations you can
have an emergency supervisor role so
right you can basically say hey if the
Dow the whole point here is that this
Borg was set authorized by the Dow given
some resources with a spe very specific
set of rules who is going to enforce
those rules right because remember there
are no owners there are no beneficiaries
there are only r rules and people who
follow them so what happens if they
don't follow them right we try to make
sure that they have to follow them with
the onchain stuff as much as possible
but it's not going to cover everything
right for example it's not going to
cover it's not going to prevent them
from transferring IP right so we need
legal rules for that well we could say
hey if the Dow passes a proposal saying
we think the Borg broke its own rules it
can appoint an emergency supervisor and
this person is authorized under both
statute and contract to come in Sue in
the name of the Dow investigate hold
people responsible remove people who
broke the rules that sort of thing it's
kind of like a nuclear option on the
offchain legal
side uh amendments right this would be a
way that everything could be rugged
right if the board of directors is has
the authority to amend the bylaws and
the bylaws are the things that say Hey
use the IP to the benefit of Lido or
whatever well that's a potential big end
run right they could just amend it and
expand it or whatever so you need a rule
that says any Amendment also requires
like a dow Vote or it could be the vote
of some other multisig or some other
Foundation entity or whatever right but
the point is you you trust minimize
it uh and kind of like the last
technique is like uh people if these
borgs are going to be entering into
legal agreements with people the broader
Community probably wants transparency on
that so one thing we're doing is what we
call ricardian triplers this has a
technical definition which I don't have
time to give you right now but the basic
idea is like you can have a standard
agreement and if if someone is signing
up to the multisig well they would just
sign this on chain and the variables are
literally instantiated on chain right so
anyone could look at the chain and
reconstruct they could look at the chain
plus the ipfs hash of this agreement
which would have been in the function
call and they can know exactly what
agreements this has and who agreed to
them and who signed it um so that's
that's really it one kind of like big
meme I will just give you guys that I
wasn't able to like fit into this very
short presentation is like think about
the modular Trend in blockchains
generally right you have these big big
highly decentralized highly autonomous
l1s and then you have l2s that are more
centralized but also sort of like more
Expendable right um and they feedback
they have feedback loops with the
L1 what have we just described with
borgs and Dows same thing right it's the
same exact Trend we now have modular
designs you can have a dow that's
surrounded by a bunch of borgs just like
you could have ethereum that's
surrounded by a bunch of l2s right so
there's this nice power ISM there and
that's really
[Applause]
it awesome Gabriel thank you so much we
have time for one question so who wants
to go and be the lucky person one
question for
Gabriel who here please at the
microphone it's coming to you it's
coming to you uh Gabriel thank you very
much for the the presentation I would
love to have it because there is lots of
available stuff um my question is that
do you think if there will be a market
for the borgs for instance like if the
different organizations could like um uh
shop for different borgs that uh provide
certain functions to it yeah absolutely
and I think there could be like even a
market for like the implants right like
you can just add and remove implants as
you need them as your organization
evolves and uh we talked about the Dow
jent here but actually I think the same
approach makes sense for any type of
entity right your ordinary Corporation
well the board of directors could be a
safe the the stockholders can be like a
tokenized dow with like tokenized shares
that vote and everything can be much
more transparent and in my opinion
efficient right because right now if you
do um like a like a board of directors
resolution let's it's called an action
by written consent in Delaware well
that's saying something should be done
or it's author izing something to happen
but it's not the it doesn't in one and
the same moment actually cause the
transaction to happen but if your
written consents are safe signatures in
one and the same and it's authorizing
sending the money somewhere in one and
the same action of approving it you're
also doing it right so so it's just
obvious to me that that it's much more
efficient and much more powerful much
more composable all those things and I
think we will have yeah marketplaces
that have these implants marketplac that
have borgs and once if they're all in
the the same standard it actually makes
them much easier to do deals with each
other like imagine a merger of two
corpor two bored up corporations where
the tokenized shares are on the same
standard so that literally you could
just call a function and one mer one set
of shares merges into the other right on
chain um so that's the kind of stuff
we're we're trying to build at my
company Metal
X thank you so much please giving a
great Applause I appreciate that Gabriel
uh so don't leave we have just a few
minutes to go to the next
[Music]
session e
is
[Music]
okay so before going next I'll want to
remind you to
even uh scan the QR code that we have
here with the session or you can go to
your to your passport go to the session
scroll down and find on the right bottom
corner at speaker questions to uh so we
can have your questions ready for the
end of the session so coming
next the next generation of the
centralized governance
it's going uh to be a talk by Trey
kopter who is as a fun fact he say an an
extincted dinosaur and he's joining us
today so please give him a warm welcome
to
[Music]
drop hey
everybody all right so yeah I'm really
happy to be here take a moment to just
enjoy that for a
second hey everyone so I'm going to be
speaking about decentralized governance
today um I'm trachy opck I'm a dinosaur
I um I'm the chief governance officer at
igen Lair or at the igen foundation
that's where I'm working previously I
worked at I was a contributor to urine
Finance where gentleman who's leaving
right now who spoke before Gabe shapir
and I both designed a governance system
called constrained delegation which
informs a lot of the work that you just
saw in borgs and also what we're
building at I there um I also was a
co-founder of coordinate which is a
system for decentralized
compensation so I want to start like why
does it even matter you know why do we
need decentralized governance why is it
important um I think we talked a lot
about governance minimization which is
really important if you can minimize it
do but what in there's no way to
minimize things at the frontier you know
you can't reduce the most new confusing
misunderstood things into immutable code
there are periods where human beings
have to come together in subjective
reality and reason things out and make
decisions together we need some form of
collective decision- making we always
will um and the forms that we have now
and have for centuries aren't so great
they lead to Wars and various other
things so beyond just the ability to
launch a token and not get sued
decentralized governance has the
potential to do much much more uh it has
the potential to
give us ways to not stop killing each
other for instance which we haven't
figured out um as a species it's a tall
order uh and there's a lot to do to get
there obviously but you know here we
have three predators that are already
doing it so this is we're going to take
our cues from them um I want to talk a
little bit about why what Dows are doing
now before we talk about the future
decentralized governance so today uh
Dows are really good things like
increased transparency in organizations
beautiful more permissionless access to
information and
control uh capture resistance all these
onchain uh Technologies allow for much
greater security and to reduce capture
by small
groups give more access to people and
they allow for decentralized
decision-making which has been an
incredible Advance over the past um you
know five years eight years but it's not
all happy stories right there's a sad
dog as well
um for instance Dows are pretty bad at
Power concentration if you look at a lot
of decent what seem like decentralized
Dows you find that under the hood
they're maybe not so
decentralized they're also bad at skill
task matching which is something we'll
talk about a little bit more um there's
tons of principal agent problems all
throughout Dows and low
accountability and while they're doing
decentralized decision- making I'd argue
that it's pretty ineffective lowquality
decision- making in most
cases so what's the next Generation so
far we've done well at decentralizing
but what's next and it's it's pretty
simple it's making them decentralized
and effective which we don't really have
any examples of today but we're getting
there and so that's what we're working
on at igen layer so igen layer we're
doing ethereum reaking helping create uh
new ecosystem of avss and um taking
things off chain putting them onchain on
ethereum to expand what's possible um
this is a big ambitious Vision it's a
big open ecosystem that we're building
and we need effective and decentralized
governance we need the people building
on igen lay to have control and
ownership over what happens on the
commons that we're creating together uh
and you know it has to be you know for
now it's it's a tricky question
decentralized or effective right you can
kind of choose one we don't have the
Technologies to do both yet so in the
beginning it's kind of okay to be a
little bit more centralized and if LEF
terce is out there we're not a DA yet
right we're trying but we're not yet
we're starting more centralized and
we're going to decentralize over time
and um that's because we're focusing on
quality decision-making we're not going
to give that up um and we believe that
we can do both but later over time it
really does have to be centralized
because you can only trust you know in
the beginning the participants in the
ecosystem need to know that IG is making
good DEC decisions right but over time
after the you know honeymoon period is
worn off you need to trust that they're
not going to screw you and uh that needs
to be
decentralized so we have this process we
call incubation which is our version of
progressive decentralization and in
Progressive decentralization usually you
know you have a foundation which has the
power and it controls everything and
then and then it gives like a chunk of
power to a dow and then another chunk of
power to the Dow um it's good we're
adding more gradation to this so uh our
version of this incubation we take
decentralized structures and we operate
them in the open as if they were
decentralized uh but they're controlled
by the foundation they're centralized to
start and we're not pretending they're
not right but we're doing this because
that's how we learn that's how we can
learn to make these structures actually
operate in a decentralized way and then
over time we decentralize them bit by
bit in a public you know open discussion
with the
community it's because we have two
contradictory things that we have to do
like we have billions of dollars in TV
we can't play with that you know we have
to make sure that that's secure so we
need both a minimal secure and stable
governance system to minimize risk but
we also need to do something that hasn't
been done before we need to make it
effective too that's so we have to be
radical Innovative and experimental in
order to event this
future so in order to do that we've
created we call Version Control
governance it's like a two trck system
of governance we've got the core system
which is the secure layer it's handling
just the minimal stuff that's needed to
make sure the protocols working and that
stays you know if that needs to be more
centralized okay it's as decentral as it
can be and then we have the vision track
and the vision track is where we're
experimental and we're creating the
systems that will be able to merge back
in over time into core once they've
proven themselves to be
effective so let me tell you about what
we're making so it's OV is what we're
calling it um it's this is going to be a
very brief overview we haven't launched
this stuff yet we will soon and I want
to so if there's a lot of questions some
this might not make so much sense I'm
going to make do the best I can we'll be
publishing a lot more of this over
time so in designing igov we started
kind of at the beginning um what
organizations need to do and there's
kind of three things there's decisions
there's decision makers and then there's
decision- making and that's how
organizations both centralized and
decentralized function decisions are the
same stuff that we've always had what
should we do who's in charge how much
does it cost it's variations of this so
we don't need to worry too much about
that we're not fundamentally changing
what a decision is but decision- making
decision makers there's a lot of room
for change um decision- making has done
a lot of development over the past uh
you know five years onchain voting
offchain voting multisig rough consensus
all the different things that we use to
do decentralized governance um continue
to be developed continue to need more
advancement as well decision makers need
a bit more work so decision makers are
things like unique human beings which
supposedly can make good decisions in
democracies um we also have tokens which
supposedly can make good decisions in in
Dows or delegates where you take 100% of
your voting power and you delegate it to
another human to make decisions and 100%
of the things in a dow regardless of
what they're good at or not um these are
not such great decision makers in my
view and so we're trying to improve
this the first step is we're not doing
token voting um token voting itself
I mean this is a bit of a nuanced one
because we are doing token voting but
we're not doing normal token voting
token voting in its normal form you know
is what I said you have a governance
token and whoever owns this token now
can say things about any matter they're
a security expert or they're a capital
allocation expert but this isn't true
and one of the one of the myths I think
that we that we we need to break and DOW
is I think there's a beauti there's this
idea is kind of beautiful that that
we're just going to be able to put
together a big group of strangers and
the collective intelligence of that
group just going to solve our problems
we're just going to give our
responsibility to this group and they're
just going to make things work and
that's a myth that's not true um
decision- making business operations
organizations these are things that
require responsibility accountability
relationships over time you can't just
give this to an anonymous group of
people now anonymous groups of people uh
can make certain classes of decisions
quite well but they can't do these in a
vacuum you know tal written about this
convex concave decision- making this
true that you want to you want to
estimate an average of certain types of
decision decisions a large group might
do better than a small group but again
these decisions don't happen in vacuums
so what happens is if you give this
power of of of an organization to just
the wisdom of the crowd you might get
decisions that work in in a small box
but they don't work in reality like
giving hundreds of millions of dollars
for Grants when you don't have the
ability to really oversee it um and this
is not this is not just one group many
groups make Pro decisions like this but
if you're a small group of people um
with relationships and accountability
and things at stake probably won't make
those
decisions um another thing about token
voting is that you know it's going back
tokens using a cryptoeconomic token to
you know provably make a decision about
something is not is a great system
that's great the problem is who are the
deciders that are using that and what is
the structure around it often there's
this idea about governance fatigue like
this is the problem governance fatigue
if you think governance fatigue is the
problem you're seeing the thing
completely wrong it's not that means
you're giving people the wrong jobs to
do right what you need to do is we need
to give people the right jobs to do and
they won't be
fatigued so in OV the starting premise
we're not sacrificing on decision-making
quality all decisions are made by small
groups of high context High trust domain
experts that's the foundation that's
where we
start why because there we do have a
super Intelligence on this planet and
it's not an llm and it's unsure if that
will even get there the greatest super
intelligence that we have on the planet
is a group of seven people that trust
each other and have worked together for
a long time or fewer that is the
smartest thing that we know of and we've
known this for a while but you know a
lot of research shows is after about
seven about intelligence drops about 10%
per person and once you get up to large
group sizes you get pretty
dumb uh so we're trying to hit that
sweet spot of a small group and this is
you know like a family like like a small
team this is what does the best
decision- making so we start
there uh why and then we can talk a lot
about why but if you look at the the
relationships so work in life in
Creative work it's about relationships
if you have a group you have two people
one relationship three people three
relationships then four six
relationships 10 relationships 15 each
relationship needs to be maintained each
relationship is a vector that can have
misunderstanding conflict tension
confusion so as you grow it becomes
unwieldly but you know we can manage uh
in small sizes
this is slime
mold uh it's not a on secator um so if
we wanted to keep scaling and just think
we want a homogeneous group of decision
makers the best we can think of is maybe
slime mold so slime mold is all these
different cells they're all kind of the
same cell but there's lots of them and
they make decisions as a group and they
do pretty miraculous things but you know
it's kind of limited what we need is
actually something more like a fly brain
now this is a heterogeneous group of
centralized and decentralized actors
woven together in really complicated
ways to make complicated decisions this
is what we need for
Dows and so OV starts with this idea of
small teams making decisions and it
starts with the idea of councils and
councils there a variety of councils
will talk about them is how all
decisions get made now how do the
councils get uh populated elections are
a great way to put popular people in
charge of things but not a great way to
necessarily put the right people in
charge of things we've created a system
called endorsements which is a way to
create
reputation um and decentralized
reputation is a research area that we're
super invested in and will be very
important in the future a lot of people
are working on so we'll talk more about
endorsements um and also decisions
decisions is how we actually weave all
this stuff all together and we're
working with Incredible Partners like
tally and hats and EAS and others to
build all this
stuff so this by the way is speculative
so left Terrace don't yell at me if this
isn't what happens um we plan to make a
variety of councils and using the
incubation process Powers will incubate
within foundation and then they will be
spawned into councils groups of powers
and then over time as they mature spawn
into more councils uh pending the amount
of overhead needed to make all these
things work together um but this creates
a better distribution of powers more
checks and balance balances more
specialization so each council is a
group of high trust High context expert
domain experts in the field that they're
making decisions on each councils has a
limited scope of power in the
constrained delegation model on which
they can act in and many of these will
be borgs just like what Gabe was talking
about
previously now endorsements how we find
people for these councils it's similar
to delegation uh this is a sneak peek at
the uh endorsements platform that we're
making but instead of with delegation
again you delegate 100% of your voting
power to one person with endorsements
when you sign up to be a contributor
which is our version of a delegate uh
you say what are you good at so Roger is
good at auditing governance and
Leadership and so when you trust Roger
by state by using your stake Dion and
allocating it to Roger to make decisions
it's according to those specific skills
that he's now
empowered and this does a number of
things in the system it also increases
your voice so you'll be able to signal
on all proposals we'll talk about this
in a second rather than just you know
eventually filling Council seats so I
want to talk about how decisions get
made this is um what a lot of dows the
model that a lot of dows follow so you
have token holders that can either
become delegates themselves or they can
delegate their token stake to delegates
and then those delegates vote on
proposals and those delegates then elect
councils or elect members to councils
who can also occasionally Vote or veto
on proposals so we changed this model
quite a bit um in our model token
stakers who have something at stake you
know uh they're not just holding the
tokens to sell them uh can be curators
or contributors and I'm going to pause
here for a second because this curator
one is kind of new so when you're a
curator you um are making endorsements
um so perhaps you're a token Staker but
you don't know who is the best at opsec
in this system so you can just assign
your tokens to a curator and then the
curator is the one that's paying
attention to all the contributors in the
system and and then similar actually
what Dennis was talking about previously
in the talk when when you're you know um
you want to make money from staking
tokens in a governance system you want
to make sure that the if you're if the
incentives are coming from people taking
action in governance such is our our
plan as well then you want to make sure
that your endorsements are going to
people that are going to be creating
value because you'll be incentivized for
it in the
future so curators also solve a big
problem in Dows which is liveness uh
most Dows uh there's an airdrop people
come in they claim their stuff they
delegate to they send their to a
delegate and then that never moves and
then that that token power is just not
moving and that's not a very good map of
the world for an organism for an
organism to be intelligent it needs to
create an updated map of its environment
and so liveness is key to that these
curators people who curators are are
going to be incentivized for cre keeping
a you know high quality map of who is
contributing as well as evaluating those
contributors over time which outside the
scope of this talk for now um so you can
assign a curator or you can endorse a
contributor for various skills
now the contributors that get the
highest uh endorsements with most trust
and and relevant skills can then be
eligible for councils and eventually
will automatically fill councils uh and
then councils vote on proposals but uh
token stakers need to have ultimate
Authority so they can veto proposals in
many cases that they don't agree with
and uh in the worst case they can Fork
the inter subjective igen token if the
governance gets captured
so and then the last piece here is about
expert signaling so this is how
decisions get made there's a discussion
phase then there's the council voting
phase and then after that there's the
veto period um that whole time there's a
phase of expert signaling so
contributors that have gained reputation
in the system for various skills can
weigh in on every proposal and this is a
sense-making advancement to support
Council decisions it's non binding but
it's important and the people that are
in the community need to be in
discussion right so if there's a
controversial proposal and the and the
community can discuss it experts can
signal on it and the council can vote
and the council might have some idea if
they're going to get vetoed or not
before that stage happens through this
right but you want that small group of
people to be able to take
anti-majoritarian action because they
might not know things that the rest
don't and they are there for a reason so
there's a
balance um and that's most of it so just
want to talk a little bit about the
future
um we have a lot of research to do and a
lot of work to do to make all this
happen right because this this stuff
hasn't been figured out yet that's why
it's not a doubt it's not tested we have
to we have to work on it before it's
really decentralized so there's a few
areas I really want to focus on one is
we need to create a system of
decentralized reputation um and there's
a lot of work there um there's a lot of
things I want to say about it but I
don't have time so I'm going to skip it
for now we need for decentralized
reputation to work we need decentralized
identity um and we also need evaluation
systems accountability incentivization
systems for these types of decentralized
systems because if we don't have this
stuff councils can be captured but
councils should totally be able to
function in the open under the control
of a decentralized governance system and
be capture resistant if we have a lot of
these things uh we also need to do
productization Dows are a mess you know
we need to apply product development
standards to the way our Dow tooling and
systems work so that all information and
processes have ux that works people can
understand and figure out how to use and
we also need to have credible
commitments because this along with
decentralized reputation is what will
allow for these things to really
function at a high velocity and change
um you know this kind of messy beautiful
experimentation period into really the
future of work where High Velocity small
teams of groups come together in ad hoc
ways to create products and incentives
and get retroactively funded build
things deploy them and then break up and
go on to other jobs like the um the the
nature of the firm is changing
dramatically you know from these large
centralized vertically Integrated
Systems to these small groups of
autonomous Sovereign contributors able
to gain reputation to gain incentive to
make to make use of their gifts in the
world because all these problems that we
have the metac crisis everything it's
all solvable with all the gifts in all
of you and all of us in the world if we
can figure out a governance system a
system to support us in offering all of
these gifts to the world and um in
service of solving these challenges and
taking our civilization to the next
level
so that's everything I'm tricky opx
thank
[Applause]
you thank you so much thank you so much
man that was awesome and people you
finally using the application to ask the
question so we have a few questions here
already uh do you want me to I I'll use
the boats I'll use the boats to start
choosing the questions so first question
is the endorsement system is utterly
similar to expertise endorsements on
LinkedIn which were removed due to their
ineffectiveness how is this different
than LinkedIn with tokens that's a great
question and it's not oddly similar I
mean we looked at systems like LinkedIn
uh without a good system of
decentralization of of sorry of
reputation without a way to incentivize
good endorsements and punish bad rep
endorsements it's not much any different
than than LinkedIn so right now it's
quite similar in the future it will be
quite
different awesome next question consoles
with limited scope can have domain
experts that are in multiple consols
leading to a scope creep any plans for
conso service limits or requ
requirements yeah definitely there'll be
term limits and there'll be eligibility
requirements there'll be legal
Contracting in some cases uh there'll be
kyc in some cases and um I don't know I
think probably people will just be able
to be on one council at a time but there
might be some cases where it's
appropriate to be on two we'll figure
that as we go um but being on two could
create conflicts of interest that we
want to avoid we'll have to
see awesome uh tough questions the
current design seems similar to op
promise of we will decentralize what
accountability will aen have to actually
make progress we know we don't we don't
have any I mean we companies can do
whatever they want right like op doesn't
have to decentralize I think um you have
to look at what's in our interest you
know so if igen layer doesn't
decentralize I think over time that
would cause a lot of problems for us and
so we can say whatever we want but look
and see what we
do awesome so how to avoid that
delegates just elect councils who will
create things good for them than later
they will approve yeah so uh there's
three key things so I just kept it to
decentralize and effective but actually
there's a third one that's really
important too which is alignment um so
you want to it's the principal agent
problem right how do you know that your
investment broker isn't just making
trades that stack his bank account or
her bank account this is I like to turn
this around and we actually think of it
as the principal agent solution because
the the alternative is that you are both
principal and agent and nobody's got
time for that right so it's a huge
solution to be able to split things up
from you know ownership to control but
how do you keep that alignment um it's
super tricky and and most of our
research path is is designed around
solving exactly this question
decentralized reputation is a key piece
of that so if um which is also outside
the scope of this discussion but
um let's say that there's we We Believe
there's ways to incentivize uh
reputation system uh using things like
trust assignments the endorsements that
we're doing skill assignments to make it
much more aligned than it is today but
just wait we'll we'll share more on this
soon good
good any way to Transit treel like
decision structure to decentralized
structure to Transit a tree like
structure um
I I mean I'm a little confused by the
question somebody want to speak to
that a tree like structure could be
decentralized um are you saying like a
hierarchical structure uh all we can
skip it yeah okay uh we can go with the
last question and it's the control of
token holders is limited removing value
from the token plus ACR value to conso
positions instead AO is significant
significantly less power than the power
to do why token at all
then well the token isn't for governance
the token is for interest subjective
forking it's not a governance token um
but why use the token in governance well
because token holders are the owners of
the protocol um and if they always have
a governance action that they can take
which is to sell their tokens uh but
before you sell your tokens why not you
know you you should have voice as well
we believe one of the things I could
have mentioned this talk is that
everybody in the ecosystem has value the
token holders the avss The Operators the
lrts everyone building on it all the
partners all have value and one of the
the big magic of putting together a
governance system is figuring out how to
help that value flourish in the right
ways and what's the right job everybody
what's finding the right job for the
right group and token holders have a
really important job they're the ones
whose finances are at stake based on the
of the actions of the organization and
so you want to give them a lever you
want to give them a voice the problem is
giving them the voice of making all
decisions for a DA is is just not a very
good connection of skills and
opportunity right um or skills and
challenge so what is the appropriate
voice for them and we feel that the
appropriate voice is it's two things
right one is deciding on who makes the
decisions right which is similar to um a
lot of forms of of of nation state
governance uh so they can endorse
contributors that then have the power to
make decisions and they're in charge of
those endorsements they're in charge of
curating the space um but then there
also have this fear response like in a
body like we're creating a body the um
there's another thing I could have
talked too there's an executive Council
that is a kind of uh Authority the top
authoritarian layer then there's expert
councils most of the councils making
these domain specific decisions then
there's the majority layer of token
holders and and reputation holders that
are that are um curating the space
vetoing the space and at the bottom
there's this self- enforcing layer of of
token
forking so yeah the token holders have a
really important role but it's just not
the role that we're used
to okay thank you so much and people
please put those hands together for TR
up the
[Applause]
risk so we'll be back in a minute please
stay and keep using the Q called as you
just made thank you so much people
[Music]
okay so we we will keep going with daos
and now is the turn to dark daos and
private coordination by Sarah Allen
please people give her a warm
[Music]
welcome all right hey everyone so I'm
Sarah Allen and today I am going to talk
about dark Dows and private coordination
um so my goal today is that I will first
introduce the technical Concepts that
you need to know to understand dark Dows
I'll give a state of knowledge on the
research that's been done since they
were identified in 2018 till present um
I will introduce some recent research
contributions and then I'll talk about
active mitigations for projects that may
want to proactively uh defend against
darkdow so first up let's talk about
private keys so private keys are must be
kept secret to be secure they're assumed
to be held by one person or entity uh
any signature given with a private key
is assumed to be created by its owner
and anything signed is assumed to be
signed with that owner's
consent so the Assumption here baked
into many of our modern systems is that
private keys are exclusively held and
used by their
owner um and because of this the
assumption that a private key is
equivalent to an identity is often
made but what if an owner could share or
rent the right to sign with their
key uh in that case private key could no
longer be used uh instead of
identity and this is the case with
incumbrance so what is incumbrance um a
secret key can be generated in a trusted
execution environment and the key then
continues to live in that te uh the te
can then be used to apply complex
policies to that private key and to its
use going forward um so here you can see
a user who's generated a private key
within a trusted execution environment
they then have access to that key but
their access is going to be mediated by
any programs that are being run by the
te so in the presence of tees and
encumbered accounts while the private
key must still be kept secret to be
secure that's the role of the trusted
execution environment in the case of an
encumbered key you can no longer assume
that that key is held by one person or
entity uh you can no longer assume that
any signature that has been made made
was done by that person or with their
consent so the single entity address
ownership assumption is what's broken by
encumbrance and given that that
assumption is made in many current
blockchain systems this has wide-
ranging
implications the implications of this
broken assumption were first identified
toward Dow voting in this 2018 post
onchain vote buying and the rise of dark
Dows by Philip Diane Tyler Kell Ian
Myers and Ari jwes and in this post they
identified a dark Dow as a decentralized
cartel that buys onchain votes opaquely
so in the
dark uh potentially nobody not even the
creator of a dark Dow can determine the
total number of participants the total
amount pledge so the treasury of the
dark Dow and the precise logic of that
dark Dow so here you can see the model
of a dark Dow so you have a collection
of Voters who've all generated
encumbered accounts uh they've pulled
their encumbered keys and now a program
can be run across all of those keys
together that's the dark Dow um the
program can be this sort of automated
vote buying in which an adversary can
bid for the right to run the program
across all of their votes so it is this
coordination trustless done through
trusted execution environments that
could be coordinated to vote and
DOW so that 2018 blog post uh suggested
the concept of dark Dows but it became
more Concrete in 2023 in Dow
decentralization voting block entropy
bribery and dark Dows uh this paper was
co-led by James Austin and Andre FAA um
I contributed as did kushall Babble MIM
n kelar and Ari jwes and this paper had
two main contributions so the first was
a new concept of decentralization in
Dows which we call Vibe or voting block
entropy uh Vibe conceptualizes
decentralization and Dows as the blocks
of Voters with aligned utility
functions and so that contribution uh
aimed to model decentral ation in Dows
as something that would be sensitive to
things like private coordination through
dark Dows the second main contribution
of the paper was this model of a dark
Dow led by James Austin so we were able
to create a prototype of a dark Dow that
could currently be used in ethereum
Dows so we did two different prototypes
this is the first one um and I'll
provide a research list at the end of
this talk and also share it on Twitter
um if you're interested in checking out
the repository um but this first one is
a set of contracts so they solidity
smart contracts uh which could be
applied to ethereum they use Oasis which
is a trusted execution environment
blockchain as their backend um and you
can see here that they could be applied
so the policy that I've highlighted here
could be applied for voting and
snapshot um secondly uh we created
something called a dark Dow light um so
this you can think of this as sort of
liquid staking for governance votes and
um this is more user friendly because
users wouldn't need to encumber their
own Keys rather they would deposit their
voting tokens in a smart contract which
would then uh give them something we
called the DD token which is a token
that would have the value of their votes
plus the value of any bribes paid to
participants in the dark Dow um and we
have a demo available here too that you
can find in the research
list and these two prototypes proved the
sort of proximate and practical reality
of dark Dows although we're not aware of
any currently operating um we posit that
this is because dark Dows are an
effective coordination tool in a truly
decentralized da um and so the the
current means of sort of collusion and
coercion um or private coordination in
Dows haven't yet needed dark Dows to
support them however um the goal in
releasing these prototypes was to
highlight that this is a threat that Dow
should start thinking about and taking
proximate steps against um and I'll
point out those later in this talk
um but in the creation of that sort of
dark Dow light it occurred to us that
actually what's happening here this
encumbering of private Keys is has much
broader implications than dark Dows
themselves and so we call that
liquefaction liquefaction is an
encumbered wallet platform which allows
users to attach Rich multi-use policies
to accounts it enables the credentials
and assets of a single-end user address
to be freely rented shared or pooled and
it accomplishes these things privately
with no direct onchain traces so broadly
it enables the transfer of things
thought to be
non-transferable so what is impacted by
liquefaction this broader
tool so first let's talk about private
Dows and the important thing to note
when going through these impacted areas
is that liquefaction is this General
tool that has both pro-social and
antisocial consequences so this first
one is a particularly pro-social one
which is the you could create a DA that
is privacy preserving so its treasury is
not known and its participants are not
known on chain um this would have been
particularly helpful in the case of
constitution Dow um so Constitution da
was a dow that was coordinated to try to
pull funds to participate in an auction
for a copy of the US Constitution a
constitution Dow did not win that
auction it's not possible to know
whether they could have won the auction
had they had a privacy preserving da
however participating in a public
auction with your max bid known AKA your
treasury size certainly put them at a
disadvantage so had they incorporated as
a private D um they may have been more
competitive as a
group Next Up quadratic voting and
quadratic
funding so liquefaction and encumbrance
are important things to note for system
designers who are considering doing
quadratic voting or quadratic funding um
even if they do have strong identity
systems um this is important because so
quadratic voting quadratic funding as I
expect many of you in the room know
since we're in the Dow track um these
are system designed to subvert tyranny
of the majority so they they aim to
empower many small voices as opposed to
direct token voting um however the
problem with empowering many small
voices in the case where small voices uh
are able to sell access to their
accounts is that it would allow a whale
um to potentially Square their voting
power or their funding power so if a
whale were to separate their account
funds across many small accounts um and
those accounts were encumbered so
they're able to do that in a way that
where they can trust that they can vote
on behalf of those accounts and they can
vote with their own toket weight from
those accounts and then return the funds
to themselves after the election um that
whale is able to command much more power
than indirect token voting um so
definitely something to be aware of for
people designing those
systems next up soulbound tokens so
soulbound tokens are designed to be
non-transferable
nfts um by being non-transferable
they're supposed to have this special
sense of identity that sits with that
user account for its whole
lifespan however if a soulbound token is
sent to an encumbered account then the
user who owns that account is able to
rent out fractionalize or potentially
sell the access to that soulbound token
while retaining the soulbound token in
their initial account so they won't have
broken the policy in any detectable
onchain way for that so bound token uh
but that soulbound token will no longer
be non-transferable in
practice next up rights to aird drops
and activity based
rewards so rights to airdrops um are
often or can be predicted for accounts
ahead of time um however the there has
not been a way to my knowledge for this
sort of Speculator class to arrive for
individual airdrop rights um but if
individuals en cumber their accounts to
which they may receive future aird drops
then they could potentially sell the
right to receive aird drops to their
account in a way that is trust minimized
for the um these speculators who might
buy those rights um but would unlock
liquidity for those users at an earlier
date than the airdrop itself um and then
similarly activity based rewards so
decentralized exchanges and some other
services provide for instance better
trading fees for users who do a lot of
volume do lot of trading have a long
history uh an encumbered account could
be shared across many users even those
who don't know or trust one another and
so they could sort of pull their
activity to get these rewards like lower
trading fees together on their
accounts uh next up dusting attacks so
dusting attacks are um the sending of
potentially unwanted tokens to many
addresses at least to current date there
isn't a way to prove whether or not you
have custody of those funds so they've
been sent to you now your account is
potentially tainted um however using an
encumbered wallet you can prove whether
or not you have access to those tokens
and whether or not you truly hold in
custody them so you could provide a
proof that you do not actually own or
command those tainted
tokens next up lock
tokens so when projects issue tokens for
Grants to investors to early project
participants those tokens are locked and
have a vesting period and that can be
automatically
enforced however if they're deposited to
encumbered accounts then individuals
could credibly sell the right to those
future unlock tokens while not
transferring them from their current
accounts um this might be desirable for
those who don't want to show an onchain
transfer that they've done this um but
do want to unlock liquidity or decrease
their stake in a protocol earlier
on next up on and offchain
transacting so transactions among
encumbered accounts could Bend what we
currently think of in terms of what
needs to happen onchain versus offchain
so for instance a set of encumbered
accounts could trade with one another um
but send only a few transactions on
chain or messages on chain that they are
making transfers among themselves um so
this would be an interesting strategy to
minimize
gas next up multi-
sigs so in a a multi signature scheme if
you encumber one member of that multisig
you could do two interesting things so
the first would be you could add
additional security by creating this
multisig of multi sigs that wouldn't be
visible on chain um so you could have
many signers not identifiable on chain
um for this multisig who need to command
each visible signature um but the second
is also a more Sinister one so a an
adversary could potentially write the
the use the use of a signature as part
of a
multisig um and then lastly allow lists
so it's much more complicated to think
about what it would mean to create a
binding allow list in a world where
users can trustless share accounts
through
encumbrance um and there are more
potential implications both pro-social
and antisocial in our upcoming
liquefaction paper um so stay tuned if
you're interested in more
so now that I've gone through the many
potential implications of incumbrance um
I'm sure many are wondering what should
one do in settings where you don't want
undetected encumbrance you want to be
sure that these things are not
possible so you'll need to use something
called a proof of complete knowledge um
this is a cryptographic technique that
was created by MIM mahimna kelar kushall
Babble Phil Diane James Austin vitalic
buan and Ari
jwes and a proof of complete knowledge
is a way to show fully unencumbered
knowledge of a
secret uh it goes beyond proving that
the key uh it does this by proving that
the key has been leaked over an insecure
Channel and it can be done with either a
te or an Asic um the te version of this
is possible to do on the local Enclave
in an Android mobile phone so uh that's
the more likely one to be
applied so where is this all taking
us incumbrance tees breaks assumptions
underlying blockchain systems and
additional measures like CK will need to
be added to systems that want to ensure
that a signer is the account owner is
also a single individual or entity and
the most practical implementation of CK
relies on
tees so in summary undetectable
encumbrance is already practical and the
defense against undetectable encumbrance
will likely rely on
tees so what's next
uh we'll need to crowdsource a more
complete list of systems that rely on
assumptions that are broken by
encumbrance we'll need to spread
awareness that the signer may not be the
account owner in current systems and
designed to either accept this or take
measures against
it for those wishing to take measures
against it they'll need to adopt
CK and we need to focus Community effort
on deep research on tees to develop an
open te for our open systems um and this
one's important it's a big project and
we're just now starting
so if you're interested in getting
involved here I would suggest that you
head to the flash Bots Forum we call
this project trustless te um and there
are some posts already available on the
writings website where you can check out
the sort of early understandings of
what's going to be involved in
developing truly open
hardware and I have a resource list here
with clickable links to all of the
papers and posts that I've discussed
today um I will also be sharing this on
Twitter and I believe the organizers are
sharing the slides as
well all right thank you for your time
and attention and thank you so much to
the
[Applause]
organizers thank you so much s for all
of this and people you haven't stared
asking questions with the QR code
so before someone start placing
questions there's someone who wants to
have the microphone and start are
breaking the eyes with the
questions there
cool uh I'm so sorry for the very basic
question but um just to make sure
encumbrance is basically like lending
someone your ID like to get into a club
or something and then just getting that
ID back what what that is that about
accurate you can think of it as lending
somebody or that is like one p policy
that a a trusted execution environment
could enforce here so you can think
about it as sort of lending your
credentials similarly to lending your ID
except that it's trustless so you could
lend anybody your ID anywhere in the
world um in a way where you don't need
to know or trust them and it's
automatically enforced and you can be
sure you'll get it back exactly when
they've said they were going to give it
back to you as opposed to having any
doubt or
trust nice we have the first question
here in the qer so what are they're most
likely dark Dows
now so I'm not sure and I don't want to
give an answer as though I am sure um my
assumption is that there are not dark
Dows currently
operating the places where dark Dows
might be more credible threats are
places that are the most decentralized
where coordinating voters to have a sort
of overwhelming share of power would not
be practicable to do personto person
anymore so if you think about Dows that
are centralized where a few whales might
be able to coordinate personally to
ensure that a vote goes in their
Direction um I would not expect that to
be a good candidate for a dark Dow
currently um if you think about a system
that is truly and ideally decentralized
where it becomes totally impossible to
coordinate people individual to
individual to get this overwhelming
share of votes that you need to pass
something that's when a dark Dow starts
to become relevant so it's as our
systems reach these ideals that we we've
set for them for decentralization is
when we need to most be on the lookout
for
these fantastic and we have a next
question is is there an example
implementation of
CK uh yes there is so there are a couple
of example implementations of CK um you
can find them on GitHub linked through
the paper that I have shared in the
resource list um one of them relies on
an Asic one requires on Intel sgx which
is a trusted execution environment
and one relies on the The Enclave that
is in an Android mobile phone um it's
likely also possible to develop this for
The Enclave that's within iOS or an
Apple device but it hasn't yet been
built
awesome someone having problems with the
QR code and wanting to ask a question we
still have time for more
questions well who wants to go ahead ah
we have another question seems like it's
a way for cbdcs on public
blockchains I'm not sure I understand
the question um a cbdc a central bank
digital currency is I think probably
unlikely to want the particular set of
privacy properties that a dark Dow has
um but I'd be interested to hear more if
someone wants to
elaborate please the person who wrote
the question wants to elaborate
yeah so um uh it seems like a way for
centralized entities to control like
multiple wallets um and to implement
like soft version of
cbdc on a public
blockchain so you mean it's a way for an
entity who wants to control some aspect
of a DA or a public blockchain to seize
control in an undetectable manner yeah
yeah
so I would say it's likely a large
coordination and building lift to do
this currently like I would be surprised
if this is currently ongoing and we're
unaware of it um I it's hard to
speculate on where dark Dows will go
over time um or if they will become this
sort of relevant problem um I could
imagine them being tools for useful
private coordination for groups that
have a lot of to deploy um so I I can
see your concern um but it's not one
that I've considered thank you
yeah okay awesome we don't have more
questions yes we have one more question
that
side hi thanks for the qu uh thanks for
the presentation um I had one question
what would be the difference between an
oligopoly and say dark Dows cuz I feel
the difference would be between legal
and illegal is that
correct so I would say that the dark Dow
um does not have to be lasting so it
would depend on the structure it takes
on the program that's being used um it
would be possible for a dark Dow to be
launched for just a single vote so uh
somebody coordinates a dark Dow and then
somebody launches a program that only
coordinates a group of Voters or bribes
A specific group of Voters for that
particular round of voting then once the
vote that is relevant to the whale
that's paying them is over then the
program is changed and so those voters
that had been aligned in that earlier
dark di are no longer aligned so I think
the um as I understand olop a dark Dow
might create a circumstance that looks
similarly centralized for The Round In
which that program is operating but it
would be less lasting than an oligopoly
in like a token system
so it's kind of like a bot network but
it can be turned on and off I trying I'm
struggling to understand what the
incentives of creating a bot network is
and then for just one proposal and then
turning it off unless of course that
proposal means the collapse of of the
the Dow
right so I think the it's possible that
one would be created and then
immediately dissolved but it would be
likel or my assumption would be that one
would be created but then it would have
different programs so different sort of
adversaries who want to buy its weight
for different votes so rather than one
individual who's consistently commanding
this network over time uh it might be
more temporary based on who has the
highest utility from that particular
vote Yes hi um one possible solution to
the problem could be using soulbound
tokens with a liveness check at the
point where you need to vote or for
instance or claim your airdrop so you
can't really sell or rent access to your
private key if you need to prove that
you're still the same person at that
time so it would depend on how you
structured it but I think you still
actually would need to add proof of
complete knowledge to that soulbound
token so the sort of liveness check
would need to be inclusive of this proof
of complete knowledge because otherwise
somebody who wanted to restrict the
ability to vote in an election could
permission it so that you could still uh
succeed at that liveness check so
provide the proof necessary from the
soulbound token account that it's still
sitting there and alive but then limit
the way in which you can vote in that
election so it could still say you can
produce a liveness check but then you
can only vote
Yes but that would be built into the
rules of the D or or that would be built
into the program that would be
commanding the use of the um secret Keys
within the enclaves so the dark Dow
would um create this set of rules by
which you could cast your votes but you
can do anything else from your account
um so what you need to prove is actually
that full unencumbered access to the
secret
key yeah okay I think I see what you
mean okay people thank you so much let's
please give a great Applause to
Sarah thank
you and in 4 minutes we'll go with the
next session so please let's stay
[Music]
hey
everyone so don't forget to scan the QR
code to ask your questions at the end of
the session because next session is
going to be awesome we are going to be
talking about what happens with the the
optimism retr funding and uh our speaker
today it's Carl shervon he's one of the
world leading experts on coffee Shane so
please give me a warm welcome to
[Music]
Carl thanks everyone um before getting
into crypto I did work in the coffee
supply chain and I've been getting a lot
of questions about where the best coffee
is in Bangkok and I'm still looking for
an answer so if anybody knows where to
go for some excellent specialty coffee
please hit me up would love to check
that out um today I'm going to be
talking about optimism retr funding uh
it's a experimental grants program being
run by the optimism Collective and as a
data Enthusiast it creates this
incredible substrate for looking at the
effectiveness of different Grant
programs um I'm the co-founder of an
organization called open source Observer
we're building a free analytics platform
and the community of data scientists who
care about measuring impact in the open
and so today we're going to be talking
about the impact that optimism is
achieving um and identifying some
opportunities to improve and double down
on where that impact is has been most
effective um so I guess just a quick
check um how many of the people in this
room are familiar with retr funding
optimism have all right pretty good so I
have a few slides that will be a bit of
a cursory introduction to optimism I
think the main point that I want to get
across here is that I believe this is a
really important experiment for the
world to pay attention to and to
understand regardless of whether it
succeeds or fails in the long run
there's something special and different
that is happening here and it's worth
paying attention
to so another chart um or first chart of
the day we have a lot of charts coming
um but it has a another poll how many of
you have seen this before how many of
you are familiar with the Electric
Capital developer report have you seen
this all right not as much uh awareness
this is one of the U most looked at
reports that the crypto industry puts
out and they track a metric called
monthly active developers um they've
been putting this out for for quite some
time now it's basically an indicator of
how many developers there are working
across all of crypto not just ethereum
every ecosystem is is captured here and
so what you can see from this chart is
that um things went up a lot in 2021
they kind of plateaued in 2022 and now
things have gone down um in aggregate
from a peak of around 30,000 to about
26,000 monthly active developers by this
metric to put this in comparison I
recently heard that uh Gemini which is
Google's AI platform they have 1.5
million active developers by their
account I don't know if they're
comparable U but orders of magnitude
greater than what we have here across
the crypto
industry um here's another metric uh
this one is the amount of venture
capital that has gone into crypto um
since the beginning basically this chart
stops at 2022 but there's another number
that they care about which is the total
amount of deal flow if we add this up we
get a number of around 80 billion has
gone into the space since
2016 so I think the interesting thing is
actually when you start combining these
types of data sets uh I don't have the
ability to go in and look exactly how
they calculate these things but I can
overlay the two and when I do that I can
come up with a new metric of my own and
that metric is the dollars spent per
developer retained and what you can see
here is that for every $3.1 million that
has been invested prospectively um as
risk Capital we only have one retained
developer in the industry still here to
show for that um so I think we can we
can do better and we hope to do better
the point is not just that um The
Venture Capital can improve um but
really that perspective funding is
difficult behind every one of these
deals there's a team of professionals
are researching these companies and
making bets and the reality is that it's
often quite difficult to do this and
there's an acceptance that most of these
bets are not going to work out uh so
perspective funding is hard retr funding
is based on the principle that it is
easier to identify something that has
worked looking back than to predict it
going forward um vatal kelp designed the
mechanism optimism has been rolling it
out and uh it's a pretty unique way of
creating markets around impact now to be
clear I don't think the most uh die in
the wool retr funding Maxi would say
that retr funding is the only way that
anything in the world should be funded
but the important Point here is that
right now we have a surplus of or not a
surplus but a large amount of
perspective funding and we need more
retrospec retrospective funding in the
world to Signal what things we value and
drive more people to build in those
directions and so that's what we'll be
talking about today
uh at launch optimism allocated 850
million tokens from its treasury to retr
funding this is a big deal and they made
a promise that if you create impact on
the optimism Collective you will be
rewarded for that impact what that
impact is how it will be rewarded TBD
but that's what we're here to
discuss uh now to date optimism has
deployed around 60 million op or as
least allocate not all that has gone out
the door um which is a pretty small
share of its treasury so even this is a
large sum of tokens we're still very
much in the early Innings and each round
has been designed around a specific set
of experiments hypotheses that they
wanted to test round one I think was
completely offchain it was a proof of
concept about 50 projects no
applications the selection was done I
think by the op Labs team rounds two and
three are where this program gained a
lot of recognition they were big Mega
rounds 40 million op went out in total
more than 600 projects participated
there were 100 badge holders um also
known as Citizens uh who were voting on
projects um I was a badge holder I think
there are few in the room still but they
were given this enormous task of
reviewing all these projects and
identifying which ones they thought
should deserve a certain amount of
funding in response to the mega rounds
in in 2024 this past year um
optimism uh changed the scope a little
bit and instead of having these large
Mega rounds they move to a system where
you have small smaller more tightly
scoped rounds with tighter eligibility
criteria and in those rounds they also
tested different experiments around
badge holders and guest voters and
expertise in total about 18 million has
gone out and there's more allocated um
through the end of
20124 again we're going to be looking at
the results of the program so far but
putting this in the scale of other
public goods funding experiments this is
pretty unique it's pretty large um and
my team and I at open source Observer
the fact that this was a real experiment
of significant scale was What attracted
us to want to pay attention and work at
optimism um there's a lot of economists
that like writing long papers about how
public goods funding is broken but here
was a real chance to throw magic
internet money and test whether we could
actually change the incentive landscape
um so I think people should pay
attention to this regardless of whether
they participate directly or
not but first because the only thing
that people like more than throwing
tokens around is complaining about
things on Twitter I want to address the
few myths about optimism and the program
of retr funding uh so the first myth is
that retr funding comes with conditions
the reality is the projects that receive
retr funding are getting with no strings
attached they can cash out they can
migrate their project to Salon they can
delegate to governance um or they can
keep building and what we see
continuously is that most people
actually tend to keep building on
optimism uh the second myth is that retr
funding is optimism's only Grand program
this is also not true um it is also oop
sorry it is not the only grants program
it's also not the largest grants program
optimism also runs prospective funding
uh since 2024 they've given out more
than 60 million I believe in prospective
Mission based grants and most of the
projects they receiving retr funding
have also received some form or a large
number of the products that have
received retr funding have also
participated in these prospective grants
um I think there's a uh a narrative that
optimism expects all of its teams to
work for free and pray for retr funding
this is not the case there are various
mechanisms and retr funding is just one
of them and obviously the most
experimental at this
point myth number three optimism no
longer cares about public goods you've
probably heard this before if you follow
the the optimism narrative on on Twitter
um I think this narrative really took
root after optimism changed the name of
the program but the reality is that
there was never a formal definition of
what a public good is optimism and I
kind of agree with this definition have
always viewed it as a kind of a spectrum
and the role of retr funding is to fill
the Gap is identify where is the market
not effective in rewarding impact and
using tokens strategically to fill that
Gap myth number four VCB projects have
an unfair Advantage uh we can actually
check the data on this and what we see
is that uh VC backed projects are a
relatively small number of the projects
that have received retr funding and
historically they have not performed as
well as projects that do not have um any
VC funding so at least to date VC
projects do not seem to have any unfair
Advantage even though there are some
large ones that have participated in the
rounds and myth number five is that
optimism's badge holders are super good
at deciding how much retr funding each
project deserves the reality is that we
are just humans we have other jobs in
many cases other ecosystems that we are
that we are working on and so it is very
difficult for any one badge holder to
have a a God view of all of the projects
and what they're doing and to be able to
review each one with a level of care
that that project most likely deserves
um so I think that a lot of uh improving
retr funding is going to be about
finding the right balance figuring out
what humans and algorithms are good at
so that we can make it more efficient
but at the same time ensure that we're
learning continuously how to improve the
allocations and make sure we get closer
to
impact so far so good now we're going to
get into the so what has this program
actually delivered on these promises is
it effective at rewarding impact um or
is it just a expensive well-branded
marketing
campaign uh to date optimism has
supported a lot of projects more than
700 um and there is a power law
distribution in terms of how much
funding they have received so with this
graph is showing on the xais is all of
the projects ranked by how much funding
they have received since the start of
retr funding and you can see that a
average project who's been in the
program has gotten about 40,000 op a top
one about 160 and there's a few that
have received over 500,000 at the time
probably worth more than a million
dollars um so this has been the
distribution so far it is a power law
it's not a kind of flat even
distribution and what you can see is
that the projects that tend to receive
more funding are projects that many of
you may be familiar with at the very top
you have protocol Guild you also have
teams that have focused on developing
specifically for optimism um like test
and prod you have core Primitives on the
super chain like um account abstraction
4 through 37 um EAS you also have some
of the major defi protocols like
velodrome um and social apps like Zora
you also have developer libraries like
ethers and weim and open zeppin
contracts that historically have not
received any funding um or of this scale
and so this is also creating a recurring
Revenue model for those types of
projects in any case it isn't just
funding a narrow set of defi protocols
this is a pretty expansive and diverse
set of projects that have been receiving
retr
funding and anecdotally um retr funding
has had a fair amount of impact um one
project L2 beat they wrote this um
beautiful letter at the end of one of
the rounds thanking retr funding in the
badge holders but also explaining how it
actually changed how they thought about
their purpose in the
ecosystem um we ethereum news uh this is
also one that I can really relate with
um that it was kind of a GameChanger for
them receiving retr funding it allowed
them to work on this and not pursue
other things at open source Observer um
this was definitely a game changer for
us and gave us the confidence to leave
start a new organization and focus on
building for optimism um so are we a few
outliers or is there some meaningful
signal
here at open source Observer um the the
project that I'm working on WE track
cohorts of other projects and
collections to see how they perform over
time and one of the things that we can
clearly see in the data if you remember
that developer Capital report I showed
at the beginning the trend line for
optimism projects especially ones that
have Reed retr funding is different on
the xaxis here you have time we have a
few Milestones um related to retr
funding three the biggest round and you
can see on the y- axis the number of
monthly active developers that have been
participating in those in in the program
both before and then coming out the
other side and you know the line is up
and to the right but there could be a
lot of things that are explaining this
so the next thing we want to look at is
how would they have compared relative to
some kind of a counterfactual or control
group we're not in a position to
basically separate out the groups and do
a pure experimental test but what we can
do is create a synthetic control using
data about other ecosystems at open
source Observer we look at not just
optimism but a range of other crypto
ecosystems so we can create comparable
metrics for how projects in those
ecosystems have have performed in the
absence of receiving retr funding and so
through this we can see that there's
actually a significant increase relative
to synthetic control for projects that
received retr funding from round
three excuse
me we can do this for any number of
metrics and I've only shown a few here
but this is a a comparison of onchain
activity for projects that receive
funding from retr funding 4 around that
Focus specifically on onchain Builders
and here you can see that um there is a
pretty significant difference uh that
has happened both um around the time of
sign up but then after the results for
retr funding four were were announced
the challenge here is that there are
other confounding factors we had the
blobs excuse me um we had the Den
couldn't upgrade and as a result of that
transaction activity spiked across the
board so we can strip that out and in
this case um we don't see as clear a
signal as we saw previously with the
developer activity so this is a whole
line of research that we need to do that
we need to get better at to isolate the
impact that retr funding has had on
different excuse me on different cohort
of
projects now if we step back and look at
the overall allocation that optimism has
had so far we can see that most of the
funding has actually gone towards these
two big boxes over here so that includes
a range of governance education thank
you um education analytics projects as
well as technical contributions to the
op stack those are these two big boxes
over here and then off to the right we
have some of the categories that are
probably most critical to the success of
the super chain which have his
historically received relatively less
funding so that's about 14 million for
the onchain
builders and then about 4 million for
the developer libraries so I know
there's other programs that are other
rounds that are in in the works right
now to put more funding into developer
tooling but historically more of the
funding has actually gone in these other
areas and so that could partially
explain why there's been less impact on
the uh on the onchain activity than
General open source developer activity
so what's next um this is just one of a
number of areas that we are excited to
explore together with the optimism
Community obviously there is some
quantitative and qualitative evidence
that retr funding is having an impact
but we really aren't in a position right
now to make any causal statements about
that
impact for us at open source Observer
this is a really big area of focus in
2025 we also know and you don't need to
um bring up good heart's law just yet
but we know that it's very easy to turn
metrics into targets and to game them on
the other hand we also know that to
scale this program data is going to play
a critical role and so the real
challenge here
is finding the right balance of human
human judgment and data that can improve
decision- making um metrics should be
evolutionary as we learn more
information they should improve and we
should be able to back test the results
that we get from each of these rounds
against the metrics and the decisions
that were used to to fund those things
and ideally
incrementally improve each time around
um this is also a big area of focus for
open source observer in
2025 one of the things that we learned
from recent rounds is that technical
experts evaluate impact differently than
non-experts now this shouldn't be a
surprise to anyone um up to now the
badge holder pool that optimism has
assembled consists mostly it consists of
a mix of experts technical experts and
and
non-experts and in round five there was
an experiment that was done to actually
test the groups of experts and
non-experts prefer different projects
did they vote differently the answer
probably not surprisingly was was yes um
there are pretty big differences in how
they voted and not just on the projects
they picked but also how much funding
they thought top projects should receive
so this chart here shows some of the
most divisive projects ones that
received um a pretty big difference or
big spread between what experts thought
they deserved and what non-experts
thought they deserved um and so going
forward I think that feedback is going
to be used to improve the design a
future rounds and particularly ones that
are more technically focused ensure that
the right composition of badge holders
are equipped to um you know uh vote on
on what this product should
receive um another issue that comes up
are just like the incentives this uh
this sends to different types of
Builders uh so you have some big
projects you have some small projects
and when you have an allocation which is
not um like a very steep power law
distribution what you can what you can
see is that smaller projects there might
be an incentive to create smaller
projects or to atomize your work into
kind of a a set of very small individual
contributions um as opposed to capture
the collective impact of of a larger
team we can see this at least in in
round five where some of the products
that did the best had the smallest team
um per on a per contributor basis and so
this could create some kind of perverse
incentive for teams to fractionalize
their work as opposed to representing it
as one cohesive um one cohesive team uh
Trent from protocol Guild wrote a very
nice essay pointing out this fact and
doing some
comparisons um and then the fifth one is
that there is a trade-off between
mathematical accuracy and just The Vibes
and the spirit that comes with each of
these rounds um we quants we tend to
suck the life out of things and there's
something very special about the spirit
and The Vibes that are created around
each of these retr funding rounds and so
as the program becomes more accurate and
predictive um there could be a trade-off
in terms of the uh the energy and the
attention that this gains um because
there's less speculation and less hope
for some for some Builders we definitely
saw that round three kind of marked a
high water point in terms of the social
media attention at least that retr
funding
received um we believe that the upside
to figuring out these things and working
on these challenges has the potential to
be huge if you just look at the size of
the number of developers that are
contributing to open source is a global
movement and If This Were a nation it
would be as large as the population of
Thailand or Mexico or Germany so there
is a large Global borderless movement
around open source and historically we
have not been very good at funding it if
this for a nation the amount of funding
that it is allocating towards its public
infrastructure would be on par with Fiji
and swas land pretty pretty low down the
ranking so we need to do
better
um we at open source Observer um are
very excited to work on this problem
we're hoping to attract more data
scientists to care about the
intersection of public goods and impact
and data science and if that speaks to
you we'd love to hear from you you can
scan the QR code to get in touch um join
our Discord and for any builders that in
the room optimism is having a 7 round of
retr funding it'll be starting hopefully
um before the end of the year you can go
to retro. optimism. get all the details
there and sign up thank you very
much awesome Carl so you know next retr
funding it's coming close so take the
opportunity questions that you have for
Carl let's start that way meanwhile
please use the Q code to place your
questions uh to e so go ahead hi Carl
Thomas here hey uh thanks for the
presentation I'm uh just want to say
first of all I'm a huge advocate for
open source soare I use it all the time
my day-to-day activities always always
using libraries Frameworks which are you
don't even know open source P right um
so I wanted to go back on two slides
that you had uh previously me mentioned
um one of them was around the
development onchain activity you don't
have to go back but it's fine
um I was wondering would you I I know
you said there were a handful of other
metrics while you were speaking but you
um outline these two wondering would you
say these are the most important metrics
for measuring and eval evaluating the
impact of funded
projects um no I would say that they are
good trailing metrics so ideally if you
have if you're doing other things well
then you'll get more developers you will
get more transactions you'll get more
users but uh you probably don't want to
fund these things directly if you were
to just fund People based on the of
their team then you get very big bloated
teams you wouldn't actually get the
impact that you care about um on the
other hand they do probably correlate in
many cases with like at a high level the
growth of an ecosystem um so we don't
really I'm not in a position to say
there's there's one metric where you
should just find this thing and I think
that's that's the whole point is that we
need to test these things out in the
wild we need to combine them in
different ways and then I think over
time we'll see some kind of composite
set of metrics some which are really
good as these trailing indicators and
some which could actually be more
predictive of a future success yeah big
big search space and just a followup
question how much how much time would
you reckon that would you would need for
that for for which part for like to eval
to you you mention you need like your
Gathering data and your your to make an
inform well-informed decision how how
much time do you need to make that
decision um we see this much more as
like a community uh a challenge for the
community so we can definitely come up
with metrics ourself but increasingly we
want to partner with with data teams um
you know projects themselves people that
have an intuition about what metrics
they think are most useful and test
those out experiment with them and you
know everything all the metrics that
we're building are are fully open so
people can come and and test them out
directly directly thank you
yeah now we have some questions here one
is what if what are the opportunities
for data scientists to get
involved yeah so um scan the QR code we
have a number of contribution
opportunities some are pretty big basic
just like helping add update um process
data what we're really looking for help
is people that have the ability to do
kind of modeling um so you know strong
python skills they're able to do things
like the the causal analysis that we
showed um they're able to process uh you
know help help us connect new data sets
and process larger and larger amounts of
data um anyone who has the ability to
kind of formulate research questions and
then design a study around that would be
super welcome um but also people that
just want to uh you know create front
ends and boards on top of it there's a
lot of of cool things you can
do great awesome and for for how long is
optimism going to be running ret PGA
fronts um I think the answer probably
forever uh that would be the that would
be the goal um certainly the the plan is
that once the the treasury the initial
treasury runs out that there's a
continuous source of funding that will
come in from sequencer fees or from
other sources of of onchain Revenue uh I
think the goal eventually is that
everything that is happening in optimism
getss funded by retr funding whether
that takes 5 years or 10 years remains
to be seen um but the goal is that this
is a system that that runs
forever awesome Carl appreciate it and
appreciate all the questions you have we
just run out of time so please give a
great Applause to Carl thank you
everyone and optimism thank you so
much so we have three more lining tolls
today so please stay in Just 4 minutes
we will keep going
[Music]
TR
m
[Music]
he
back
[Music]
hey everyone coming next next we have a
talk about common knowledge and how this
uh Community PA is a possibility to have
a mechanism to leverage diversification
and zero knowledge Pro proofs to help
people so we have tonight puya all to
talk about common knowledge machines
please give her a warm welcome
[Music]
all right
so let me get this on the right slide
here common knowledge so what is common
knowledge why does it matter so common
knowledge is not just that you know I'm
standing here it's that you know that I
know that you know at infinitum it's a
very different thing than just knowing
that I'm here and a classic example of
this is the Romanian revolution in 1989
for everyone for years everyone knew
that this dictator
chesu was a tyrant um but nothing ever
happened and it wasn't until actually uh
a simple act during one of his public
speeches a live broadcast whistle that
cascaded into many whistles that a
revolution began and the key wasn't just
that everybody saw that key was not just
that everybody was unhappy but they saw
that everybody else was
unhappy so we've had similar moments in
American history I'm American so that's
my history um but my contention is
actually common knowledge is getting
harder to get off the ground and that's
because of increasing Pol political
polarization and while political
polarization predates the internet it
certainly has been accelerated in the
digital age and why is this so bad well
if we can't find Common Ground if we
can't have shared beliefs then
Collective action becomes really hard
and Collective action is the stuff for
political movements and also for
government and legitimate governance and
so on the international stage this is
really important so unions stay unified
and can differentiate their allies from
their adversaries and Marshall support
and not collapse into the chaos of
competing narratives which we seem to be
trending towards and also common
knowledge lets us solve higher forms of
cooperation problem for example like
climate change that requires consensus
and agreement about the
facts so since this is Devcon and an
ethereum conference it's worth
acknowledging actually that ethereum
itself is an example of a common
knowledge machine it produces or it
seeks to actually produce an immutable
Ledger about shared Global State um
another obvious example of Comm
knowledge machines are things like blue
sky forecast or lens or X these are the
functional equivalent of public squares
but actually online but of course here
common knowledge rarely ever gets off
the ground and instead we just have
divisions and competing narratives about
reality and which one is true so today I
want to introduce a quick mechanism and
outline on the principles um to sort of
nudge your thoughts and you can read
more um if you want in my writings um so
the idea is called Community post and
everybody here who participates in some
social media platform has some set of
followers and the idea is instead of
blasting a post to all of your followers
you first stress test a post across
different groups of followers who don't
necessarily talk listen or agree with
one another to gauge what resonates
before it's widely shared and so here's
how it works
um if you look at your followers your
set of followers they actually all have
differences in Behavior measured by
their likes their reposts who follows
them and who they follow their
connections and you can aggregate this
information about observe Behavior using
things like ZK snarks and put people in
clusters as represented by circles here
and the idea is that you pick a subset
of uncorrelated followers on your social
graph people who behave differently on
the platform balance for reach with a
minimum diversification threshold
now these polarity subsets aren't an
echo chamber what they are is a sampling
or random sampling of a subset of your
fans followers balanced across different
perspectives and there'll be multiple
subsets to choose from for example you
can handpick key anchors or key thought
leaders or experts and then diversify
against them in different combinations
to fill the remaining set now once you
pick your subset you send that post to
the subset with a zero knowledge proof
confirming that recipients follow you
without revealing your identity now some
might disagree with at the post and send
ZK feedback to you but some might
actually take it further and pass it on
to subsets polarity subsets of their
followers and these rounds repeat
forming a tree of polarity subsets
across a social graph which essentially
pushes your post across very diverse
parts of the social graph allowing you
to grage cross tribal appeal at every
step and every layer through repost
rates and feedback and of course the
people who receive this get a
notification ZK posted by the people you
follow or and people you follow boosted
this post and so on now the final step
is the post goes public once it gains
enough support across it reaches a
diversification threshold and it's
passed its social stress test and the
post goes public and you can merge into
your open feed and anyone who has
reposted it can post it to all their
followers and so on and then you know
any remaining divides as represented by
Red here on these red uh RED parts of
the social graph you can use Community
notes which we're all familiar with to
bridge um in add context and this is
really lwh hanging fruit divides um so
anyways this is the summary of the
mechanism um I think it works because
essentially what you're doing is you're
reversing the cycle that happens on
social media of context collapse
controversy cancellation and capture and
these are things where social media
leverages divisions to create more
divisions and you reverse that cycle
with diversification discounts and
bridging to restore Common Ground um
okay I think that's it for five minutes
I can take any of your
[Applause]
questions that was kind of a complex
mechanism for five
minutes want ask a
question who who wants to ask a question
here
please this is amazing what do we do
next what's like a Next Step here yeah
so there are a lot of um experiments
with uh social graphs right now in web 3
um forecaster and lens are an example
and so you can leverage like ZK snarks
um zero knowledge proofs to actually
calculate this information without
revealing you know the identities and
participants in a social graph and start
to engra you know create a more
meaningful parallel attention feed to
show okay like what are what are posts
where there's wide agreement on and
instead of focusing on like the
attention and the rage bait that comes
from a global attention auction you can
focus your attention on okay what are
the things where there's agreement and
then build on that
agreement
yeah one more
question um do you
envision uh this being applicable to
like more popular social media like
maybe a plugin for Twitter or whatever
yeah it could apply to any social media
it could apply it's a road map for um
making x a common knowledge ma machine I
think that's actually was always the
aspiration around a Public Square um and
the chesu example um it's also
applicable to Tik Tok it's t it's
applicable to really any social network
um and it's just a more uh intelligent
uh attention mechanism right that gets
us that sort of reverses the cycle of
let me um you know hit my dopamine
receptors with division towards let me
see what I can find common ground with
and and build on that okay thank you
everybody thank you so
[Music]
much just
think thank you
[Music]
I to ask one more
but c c c c c no C
speeech
okay okay so for this was he he don't
want to
theater yes and you're just going up and
then you all you know like
invite in in the state and then going
down and after that just wait until
wasn't finished
all this
[Music]
are you ready I'm ready
okay okay everyone next we have
the Shane male gaze by Wasim Z
alindi please give him a warm
[Music]
welcome hello everybody I'm it's
slightly um out of place to have such
cheerful music introducing this talk
perhaps um so the title of it is called
the chain mail gaze and hopefully the
reasons for that will become apparent as
we go on but I'm sure you've all heard
of the male gaze and the kind of
externalities and you know
um unfavorable things that come with
that but what about the chain maale gaze
well hopefully we'll find out not got
very long so I'll try to you know give
you a survey of what's actually quite an
extensive uh anthropological and
philosophical research
project okay some pictures of big strong
men and their swords looking into the
distance perhaps thinking about lands to
conquer
a short poetic reframe the church and
the network Zeal and time death and
money all sides of the same
coin I want to talk to you about uh
interim project that led up to where
we're going to that was called profit
motives looking at the false Divinity of
capital how it animates uh motivations
and Desires in the technology space that
might not be immediately apparent
AR for as long as there's been Financial
Capital risk and speculation have
orbited manipulated and harnessed it as
narrative feedback machines
simultaneously reading and rewriting
realities markets exist as a distributed
conversation between uh among
speculators driven by profit motives and
appetite for divination and prophecy
today new strains of techn colonialism
are emerging which are the latest of a
series of Echoes throughout Western
history and ascendant cabal of
Technology Elites are attempting to
reshape the world in their favor whilst
hiding in plain sight behind the
technologies that have enriched them
theirs is a Promethean zeelot Tre
without faith affecting an aura of
design Divine sanction for the purposes
of elevating the ego enriching the
chosen ones and creating empires of
various Stripes but was it not always
so I want to read you a short story
fictional speculation about where we
might be going in the future and it's
called seething like a
state de centralization has a cost the
price of Anarchy the price is always due
but the rewards weren't cheap to reap so
solid ccru what most did not expect was
that payment would become due at the
grandest scales of governance the West
failure State forged under the fire of
peer pressure was ambushed by upstart
modes of power opening new vistas of
communication modification and communion
the orientations that nation states had
used to enshrine their power only made
it easier to undermine them the bigger
they were the harder they fell brex
Topia the European Union NATO's cave the
United State machine all returned to
dust the decline in the nation state of
the nation state in the Roaring 20s
became a cannon of canonicity for an
entire generation of Soul Traders it
wasn't even just the bit levers in those
days there were many networks many
Messiah many ideolog Logics all with
their own profit
motives so many of you have doubt
doubtless heard of this concept of the
network state that has emerged in the
last few years um exit fantasies
arguably fueled by the failure or the uh
shortcomings the shortfall of the full
promise and the dream of web 3 I'm going
to read you a short section from baji
fan self-titled book 2022 a network
state is a social network with a moral
Innovation a sense of national
Consciousness a recognized founder a
capacity for Collective action an
in-person level of Civility an
integrated cryptocurrency a conceptual a
consensual government limited by a
social smart contract an archipelago of
crowdfunded physical territories a
virtual capital and an onchain census
that proves a large enough population
income a real estate footprint to attain
a measure of diplomatic recognition the
magic words in here are recognized
founder and diplomatic recognition well
and territory I would say so these
projects carry echoes in my mind at
least of some of the earliest
um Expeditions that set out from the
West in search of new territories to
conquer and
subjugate so many of you have doubtless
heard of things like Liber land Sealand
seasteading institutes uh you know this
is the zahi designed metaverse HQ of
liberland on the screen here um there's
been so many attempts to make like
crypto Islands uh Bitcoin cruise ships
and they've all failed it's quite
interesting but what seems to be
different now is the level of capital at
at on hand as a result of Market success
of these Technologies to the people that
want to shaped the map of the world in
their own you know uh uh to their own
preferences to their own cause we know
that leaders of nation states we even
have leaders of nation states that are
uh cheerleading some of these
Technologies uh n k the authoritarian
strong man in El Salvador would like to
build a Bitcoin City uh financed by
volcano Bonds in his country he's not
done it yet but meanwhile he's removed
the Judiciary removed term limits and
instituted one party Rule and most of
the Bitcoins are cheering the this on so
I ask myself are we still in this for
the
freedom and now you know made possible
by ethereum Dows and all the rest of it
we have projects like Al herbit and even
prais Praxis and on the left and prosper
on the right so these projects are
trying to build physical cities private
territories Network States um or at
least the you know what may develop into
the Bagan concept of the nation state
it's a this point I want to introduce
the chain mail
gaze today's Tech overlords are the
descendants of Europe's Crusaders well
financed zealous Fanatics wreaking
destruction on the planetary other in
the name of their greater good the
Vatican sponsored waves of Le invasions
that began in the late 11th century with
the Midwife of capitalism colonialism
and Technology as we know it today with
the network day organizational concept a
card rayer of power ful ideologues
blessed with tokenized wealth a toying
with the prospect of reshaping National
Frontiers mirroring the desires of
Frankish noblemen and their nightly
orders a thou in the Levant a thousand
years ago and that's all the time I have
7 minutes for a thousand years of
Western history thank you very
much thank you Wasim that was awesome
now we have the latest and not but not
least talk of the day we will have in
just a few minutes uh the last
conversation I want
to uh take this time also to invite you
tomorrow to come to stage two we will
have several talks here the whole day
and afternoon and now with my coffee my
cial design patterns for web tree and
Beyond we have Jeff EMT please give a
warm welcome to
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff yes Mofi I know it often gets read
my coffee um we're working on that with
the capitalization here but um really my
Kofi is um my cial finance it's
microeconomics um it's learning from
mushrooms and uh you know learning from
fungal wisdom for the future of Finance
how can we apply these design patterns
um to web 3 and Beyond uh and Mofi
really comes from you know defi was
decentralized Finance we have
regenerative Finance you guys all know
this Kofi collaborative Finance quite
new to the space really interesting you
should check it out uh and my Kofi was a
kind of a joke that came out of uh the
Kofi conference and has gotten way more
popular I'm sorry Kofi um so why should
we learn from mushrooms uh well we
should listen to our ancestors uh
mushrooms are actually uh our ancestor
they we evolved from them at some
distant point of the um Evolution um we
are closer related to mushrooms than to
plants or many other forms of life uh
and they have so much to teach us um
they are the regenerative economy of
nature um there are lots of design
principles these are only six that we
identified for this book uh Mofi that we
wrote with uh Kevin aaki uh in the green
pill Network along with Scott Morris
Jessica zartler a number of researchers
um and looking at these um six
principles in three different lenses one
how the mushrooms do it uh two how it
works in web 3 today there's lots of
examples of Mofi I would say under
underground maybe in web 3 uh and then
third what can we do in the future with
these Technologies and these principles
um so running through them quickly
because we've only got a few minutes
here um how our Network infrastructures
you know melium and blockchains are
actually quite similar um you know
melium is uh the network of the for the
wood Wide Web I'm sure a lot of you have
heard about that mushrooms are having
quite a a hey day um and very similar to
blockchain networks in a lot of ways we
won't go through everything just to get
through all the principles but you can
read a lot more about it in the book um
their fractal nature um self-similarity
there's a lot of efficiency in design uh
for these types of um of uh
infrastructures uh emergent coordination
how they coordinate from the bottom up
learning from the edges of the network
um things like quadratic funding
actually is a really interesting way uh
to gather sort of emergent signal from
communities and then allocate funding
matching
quadratically uh fungi are the original
Dows um they share information they
distribute resources they make decisions
and they navigate change very
effectively uh so we can learn a lot
from these
organisms Dynamic flow um there's no
locking in mushrooms everything flows
all the time continuous resource
distribution through the network um we
can learn so much from these you know
there's lots of examples like radical
drips um pushing funding to dependencies
uh conviction voting flowing our voting
power inverting inverter network is
working on Dynamic token issuance um
lots of interesting examples of dynamic
flow in web 3 systems
today Mutual reciprocity um we've you
know four billion years of mutual
benefit um is what mushrooms have
delivered to all of these different
ecosystems I don't know if you are aware
that my ium is kind of like the extended
nervous system of nature um trees can
recognize feed and communicate with each
other they make forests into networks of
mesh stability uh up to 75% of plants
Roots can be entangled in mycelial webs
nine out of every 10 trees on the planet
is connected to a melal network um so we
have this really strong resilient um
kind of underground socialism through
these mycelial
networks uh and they encourage
polycentric pluralism um diversity
weaves that resilience um mushrooms can
have up to 20,000 different genders if
you didn't know that um so very
pluralistic they're um
experimenters so um so why should we
learn from fungi again um you know they
have so much to teach us uh there's no
mono in M um moving from monoculture
currencies to permaculture currencies um
how can we create different um baskets
of resources to serve different societal
niches that are horribly UND served by
the current
system and what's our goal here if we
can take down you know this current
system not by um you know fighting it
directly but actually by composting it
by breaking down the parts that aren't
working by reutilizing those resources
from the bottom up serving the core
needs of community uh I think we have
a I don't think capitalism has a
Fighting Chance
actually so this is the book we wrote um
if you haven't read it yet free copy is
on the top hard copy if you want to
purchase one is on the bottom uh you can
definitely check that out and we have a
few copies actually out in fungi
sink if you haven't seen the exhibit out
in the main hall uh great area lots of
really cool art and we'll be hanging out
there talking a lot about my Kofi thanks
very
[Music]
much thank you very much je that was
amazing and who wants to ask a question
to Jeff and we bring the
microphone is the last session today go
ahead why are they sharing uh Resources
with no profit
incentive it it is interesting actually
uh mushrooms do exhibit what's called
like wal rousan Market Behavior so they
do actually have profit incentives
they've hooked up melal n mats and
meshes to trees with high phosphorus and
low phosphorus and they found that the
trading rates actually change depending
on how much of the resources available
so they trade nutrients um minerals
generally to the tree and the tree
trades sugars in exchange but if the
resources are in scarcer Supply that the
exchange rates change so actually they
kind of do just in a polycentric or or
permaculture uh economy there's no one
currency it's a pluralistic uh profit
kind of thing
awesome we have time for one more
question one
more someone
please uh I would say inverter network
is really exciting um very sort of like
modular composable um toolkit they're
working on a lot of these um flow um
tools for flow um allocation of uh token
distributions um I mean obviously
gitcoin a lot of these uh projects
giveth givebacks wow there's so many um
really cool opportunities qac if you
haven't heard of qac everyone here knows
daac there's now quadratic accelerators
which is kind of a bonding curve cross
quadratic funding mix um really cool
Innovation coming out of the space
um yeah there's there's so much going on
here I'm sure actually this crowd
probably knows more than me because
there's so much uh Innovation between
every conference and uh there's just so
much to keep up with so it's exciting
times that's right exciting times with
all the Innovation we have seen here in
Def all these latest years we have one
more question uh time so who wants
to one more one more
question
okay um what was that was it like the
modular tokens or something that you
mentioned
before um I guess well if I was speaking
about inverter networks so they're
they're working on sort of modular
components so you can have sort of
issuance mechanisms allocation
mechanisms decision-making mechanisms
but without sort of one hardcoded uh Dow
um experience you can plug in different
you might have quadratic funding for one
Dow but a different group wants to do
conviction voting um some group might
want to have a bonding curve for their
token issuance maybe someone else else
wants something more like a liquidity
bootstrapping pool or you know there's
all sorts of different um modules that
can plug in to create uh more complex
token systems and I think this is
actually really you know if you think
about Computing as well how do we have
such an infinite diversity of computing
while we have chips you know and chips
can be combined in all sorts of
different ways and then we get really
incredible technology so I think we're
starting to Verge on this on the
economic institutional uh side of things
and I think these toolkits are a really
interesting Way Forward
awesome people please put your hands
together for Jeff thank you so much
man and everyone thank you it was a
great great day here at stage two we
wait for you tomorrow again enjoy the
conference enjoy bangok and see you
later thank you very much my name is
Julio Cesar and it was a pleasure to be
here with you today have a great
one for
[Music]
a
[Applause]
to
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
m
oh
[Music]
to m